SUBCOMMITTEE SINCE WE CAN'T AND
WE WANT TO GET OUT OF HERE
SINCE I SEE- THANKFULLY THE
MISTER GLAZIER HE IS HERE- TO
PRESENT- AND IT LOOKS LIKE.
SEVEN NINETY TWO SB SEVEN
NINETY TWO- IT WILL ENJOY A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION SOON AS WE
ARE IN FULL COMMITTEE SO YOU
MAY PROCEED MR GLACIER. WORKING
IT IS NOT OKAY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS- IT BUT NOW I'M
HERE AND YOU'RE SITTING AT HOME
IN SAN DIEGO AND OTHER. ROGER.
ALSO TO GO ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE
ALL RIGHT HELLO GOOD MORNING.
WORKING OKAY THIS IS. IT'S NOT
KNOWN. OKAY THAT'S WHY I
THOUGHT PART OF. OKAY SO YOU
COULD NOT OKAY THERE YOU GO
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. NOT YOU
KNOW THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR YU
KNOW OUR TAX CODE CAN BE PRETTY
OBSCURE AND I THOUGHT I WOULD
TAKE THIS BILL AND TRY TO PUT
IT IN PRAGMATIC TERMS. MANAGER
IF YOU'RE SITTING AT HOME IN
SAN DIEGO AND YOU JUST AT THE
SIDE THAT YOUR TEN YEAR OLD
COMPUTER NEEDS TO BE REPLACED
AND SO YOU WANT TO ORDER ONE.
AND HE DECIDED DO IT ONLINE SO
YOU AND YOU MADE THE CHOICE YOU
WANT TO ORDER AN APPLE COMPUTER
YOU ORDER THE COMPUTER A FEW
DAYS LATER A TRUCK COMES
RUMBLING DOWN YOUR STREET IN
SAN DIEGO HOPEFULLY NOT MAKING
TOO MANY MORE POTHOLES AND
DELIVERS THAT COMPUTER Q. YOUR
HOPE IS THAT. THOSE IMPACTS TO
YOUR COMMUNITY THE TAX MONEY
THAT'S A CHARGE WILL GO TO YOUR
COMMUNITY. BUT IN THIS CASE AND
IN MANY CASES IT DOESN'T. UNDER
ARE SECURE- SOMETIMES WORKS TAX
CODE. THE AT TAXES FOR YOUR KID
YOUR PURCHASE ACTUALLY WILL GO
TO THE CITY OF CUPERTINO. AND
WHY IS THAT BECAUSE APPLE HAS
MADE AN AGREEMENT WITH
CUPERTINO THAT SAID THAT ANY
COMPUTER THAT'S ORDERED ONLINE
IN CALIFORNIA WILL BE
CONSIDERED. AS CUPERTINO IS THE
PLACE OF SALE. AND SO THE TAXES
WILL GO TO CUPERTINO AND HOW
DID THAT ARRANGEMENT HAPPEN IT
HAPPENED BECAUSE- APPLE SAID
WE'RE GONNA DESIGNATE CUPERTINO
WAS THE LOCATION IF YOU RETURN
HALF OF THOSE TAX MONIES TO US.
AND SO UNFORTUNATELY IN OUR TAX
CODE THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN. THIS
MANIPULATION EXIST. AND IT'S
NOT JUST APPLE IT'S THE BIGGEST
COMPANIES IN THE WORLD AT THE
WALMART. IT'S TARGET IT'S EBAY
THERE'S JUST SO MANY SO HOW DO
WE AT. COME DUE AT A GOOD
REASON DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT
ISSUE OF OUR TAX CODE AND THIS
BILL IS ONE OF THOSE BUILDING
BLOCKS TO HAVING THAT HAPPEN
AND THAT'S TO GET THE FACTS. ON
HOW THE SALES TAXES ARE
COLLECTED IN OUR STATE. HOW
THEY'RE DISTRIBUTED AND THEN WE
CAN HAVE A ROBUST DEBATE ABOUT
WHETHER THAT FAIRNESS IN OUR
TAX CODE EXISTS OR DOESN'T AND
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL
THAT'S BEFORE YOU. BOB OKAY
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA- GO AHEAD
AND TAKE A MOMENT AND-
ESTABLISH QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY. GONZALEZ PRESIDENT.
BIGELOW PRESIDENT BRIAN.
CALDERON PRESENT CORREO. SHALL
DALAI. VOEPEL FOR DATING. BONTA
MULLIN FOR GABRIEL. IT WATER
GARCIA. THREE OF US FOR THE
GAME BURKE. POWER FOR ROBBERY
THIS. STONE FOR WEBER. MCCARTY
FOR VACANCY. RIGHT- CLEARLY WE
HAVE A LOT OF SUBSTITUTES TODAY
SO I AM WE WILL GET THROUGH WE
ARE ON MISTER GLACIERS- SEVEN
NINETY TWO IT HAS A NEW HAS
RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A MOTION
BY DOCTOR PARK A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO. HE MADE A PRESENTATION
SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND TAKE IT
TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR.
ANYONE IN SUPPORT- I YOU DO
HAVE A WITNESS DO NOT MISTER
WHICH I DO JOHNNY- PAYING OUT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CITIES. OKAY WE'LL GO TO THE
WITNESS ON THE PHONE. THE
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS. JOHNNY
PINA WITH A CALIFORNIA CITY.
HAS DEFINED ORDER AT SEVEN
NINETY TWO. I WANT TO START BY
SAYING THANK YOU TO BE OUT
THERE TO BRING THAT NUMBER DOES
NOT MEASURE FORWARD. THIS IS
YOUR AIMS TO BETTER INFORM THE
PUBLIC UNDERSTANDING OF ONLINE
TRANSACTION. HELLO GOOD DAY.
ORDING REQUIREMENTS UNDER THIS
BILL WOULD SUPPORT THE STUDY OF
THE IMPACT INCREASE ONLINE
SALES TAX AND- I THOUGHT ONLINE
FILLED OUT TAKING A CUT STATE.
TODAY AN ANALYSIS OF THAT
ONLINE SALES TAX IT'S
CONSTRAINED HIM THEM. OUR
LANGUAGE TRANSACTION NEED TAX
DATA FROM ONLY ABOUT HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S BORDER EIGHT
EIGHTY TO THIRTY. YEAH FRANKLY
IT AND. OKAY ADDITION. HAVING A
ROBUST INFORMATION ON THE BILL
TAX ALLOCATION IS NEEDED TO
INFORM AN EQUITABLE SALES TAX
ALLOCATION POLICY. THE MEASURE
WILL HELP US GET THAT. WHAT
HELP WILL UPDATE THAT DATA AND-
FOR THOSE REASONS I URGE AYE
VOTE ON SB SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU-
I JUST I AM SORRY BECAUSE WE'RE
SKIPPING AROUND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE KNOW THEIR HUNDRED
SEVENTY BILLS TODAY- IF YOU'RE
IN THIS ROOM YOU NEED TO MAKE
THAT TO WEAR MASKS IF YOU'RE ON
THE PHONE. AND YOU'RE NOT THE
LEAD WITNESS- WE ARE VERY
STRICT ABOUT SIMPLY STATING
YOUR NAME THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT IF ANY IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL WITH THAT
WE'LL GO TO PHONE LINES ANYBODY
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION-
CENTER GLACIERS. SB. SEVEN
NINETY TWO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR UP FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK. TO BILL SEVEN NINETY
TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME PRESS ONE ZERO. I'M
GONNA GO TO LINE. SEVENTY FIVE-
HOST. AND I'M THINKING THANK
YOU NOW WE'RE GOING TO BUY IT
BY THE RULES TODAY YOU SAY YOUR
NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
THAT'S IT WITHOUT WILL GOES
ONLINE. I'M ONCE AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK ON A BILL SEVEN NINETY
TWO. WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON WHO
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT.
THERE WILL
NOW GO TO LINE. NINE MISTER
CRANE SANTA MONICA HELLO HELLO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FRAZIER
CRANE SANTA MONICA REPRESENTING
THE SANTA MONICA CITY COUNCIL
AND THE NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO SB NINE.
OKAY THANK YOU AND WE WILL NOTE
THAT BUT WE ARE ON SENATOR
GLAZERS- SEVEN NINE TWO I
SHOULD HAVE IT MEMORIZED BY. IF
SOMEBODY HAS A COMMENT ON SB
SEVEN NINE TWO PLEASE SIGNALED
OPERATOR NOW IF NOT WE'RE GOING
TO BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
HELLO NOW GO TO LINE I KNOW SET.
YOU DEFINITELY SHOULD HAVE IT
MEMORIZED BY NOW. WE ARE NOT
PLAYING THIS ANDREA. ADULT DONE
AND ANDREA KOPPEL MARQUEE DOWN
AS OPPOSED TO EVERY DEMOCRATIC
BILL THAT SEEMS TO BE THE
POSITION YOU HOLD. WITH THAT-
WILL BRING IT BACK TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE LOST
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OKAY
WE'RE ADAM CHAIR OF THAT. GO
AHEAD THERE YOU ARE. YOU CAN
HEAR ME NOW WE CAN YES- BUT
YOU'RE BIGELOW INAPPROPRIATE.
MILLIYET WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL IN GENERAL FUND COSTS IN
THE TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT AND A
DUPLICATES UPDATE CD TFA IS
CRAP ONLINE PORTAL THAT
PROVIDES SALES AND USE TAX
ALLOCATION THAT DATA FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. CD TFA REPORTS IN
FINANCE AGREES THAT THIS BILL
IMPOSES APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN ONE TIME. IT IS A COSTS
IN THE FOR PROFIT EDUCATION AND
THEN CD TFA ESTIMATES ON THE
COST OF APPROXIMATELY. THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND PER YEAR. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE C. NINE WILL MAKE
SURE NOBODY AND THAT I'M SORRY
I FORGOT THIS PART NOBODY WHO'S
HERE WANTS TO SPEAK I CAN
NOBODY GOING TO THE MICROPHONE-
WITH THAT AS CENTER GLACIER
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
YET. AB YOUR BILL OUT WE'RE
WAITING ON SOME DEMOCRATS TO
COME TO THIS COMMITTEE BUT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. IT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
SENATOR. ALL RIGHT SENATOR DODD
MEDICARE- OH SORRY- CENTER ON
BURGERS OUT ILL TODAY OKAY AND-
I GUESS THE QUESTION IS WOULD
IT BE POSSIBLE FOR ME TO
PRESENT ON HIS BEHALF.
ABSOLUTELY WE ARE THE EASIEST
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
PRESENT ON THEIR BEHALF SO WITH
THAT SB THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR
I'M BURKE. IT IS IT A ROLL CALL
I HAVE A LOT. MOVE THE VALVE. I
HAVE A MOTION BY I'M SORRY- I
HAVE BEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COURT A SECOND BY MR BIGELOW-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SB THIRTY
FIVE WOULD CLOSE LOOPHOLES AND
PROTECT EVER EVERY VOTER
WAITING IN LINE TO CAST THEIR
BALLOTS VERIFY THAT ONLY
ELECTION OFFICIALS MAY PLACE
OFFICIAL BALLOT BOXES AND
PREVENT THE OBSTRUCTION OF
POLLING LOCATIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY FIVE ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR ROBERT. THANK
YOU- IF ANYBODY IS ON THE PHONE
LINES WHO WANTS TO SPEAK EITHER
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB
THIRTY FIVE WILL TAKE THAT NOW.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF ANYONE
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. NOW GO TO
LINE. SEVENTY FIVE. FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU'RE FLEXIBLE WITH THE
MEMBERS BUT YOU'RE NOT FLEXIBLE
THANK YOU THAT'S YOUR THIRD
TIME ANDREA IF WE I'M
INTERRUPTUS COMMITTEE THREE
TIMES WE NO LONGER TAKE YOUR
CALLS SO OPERATOR SHE BEGINS
AGAIN PLEASE JUST CUT HER OFF
THANK YOU. NOW GO TO LINE
TWENTY SIX WHO. ONE ONE TWENTY
SIX A ONE IS OPEN. YOU WENT FOR
THE BUSINESS. WE HAVE A VERY WE
HAVE VERY CLEAR RULES AND
APPROPRIATIONS YOU ARE ALLOWED
TO STATE YOUR NAME OF YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THE POSITION
YOU HOLD IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
DO SO YOU MAY DO SO NOW. MADAM
CHAIR WE DO APOLOGIZE THE-
PERSON THAT WE'VE HAD THIS
THIS- ONGOING DISPUTE HERE WITH
HAS CALLED IN ON AT LEAST THREE
PHONE LINES- OTHERWISE WE ARE
TRACKING THE LINES AND WE DO
APOLOGIZE THAT'S OKAY I
APPRECIATE IT'S A CHALLENGE FOR
ALL OF US. AND WE ARE EXPECTING
ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT.
GOING TO GO TO LINE. SEVENTY
ONE. THE MORNING CARE AND
MEMBERS JENNIFER KENNEDY L. A.
COUNTY AYE OPPOSED SB THIRTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYMORE IN SUPPORT- I'M SURE
THERE IS. I'M GOING THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO STAY THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
NOBODY IN THE AUDIENCE I SEE
NOBODY ON COMMITTEE. AND AS I
STATED PREVIOUSLY AND- THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. I'M
AND WE CAN GO AHEAD AND
DISPENSE OF SB SEVEN NINETY TWO
BACK IT'S OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITH MISS DOLLY THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU MISTER GLAZER WHO
VERY MUCH WITH THAT SENATOR
DODD. SENATOR DO YOU HAVE SB
FIVE FIFTY SIX. IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO AS
SECOND BY- AFTER COURT YOU MAY
PROCEED RESPECTFULLY ASK
THROUGHOUT THE THANK YOU WILL
GO AHEAD AND WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES IS THERE ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO MR
DODDS SB FIVE FIVE SIX. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR THIS IS
RUDY RAMOS WITH VERIZON
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON BEHALF OF. VERIZON
CTIA AND ALMOST THIRTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA VOTERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA STICK
WITH THE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION FROM NOW ON. SB FIVE
HUNDRED ABOUT. I'M I'M HERE TO
HELP FIND THAT BELT- FIVE FIFTY
SIX OKAY. SHOULD ALL. I AM SURE
THAT WE HAVE A WITNESS YES I
JUST REALIZED THAT I AM SORRY
THE SERRA. YES MA'AM OKAY YOU
KNOW I HAD. GOOD MORNING WHERE
MEMBERS I THINK REPRESENTING
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE
THAT. THE CALIFORNIA THE
PATIENT CO SPECIAL WE ARE PROUD
OF SENATOR DODD AFTER A FEW FOR
YOU AND WE'RE HERE TO TRULY
SUPPORT CRYING OUR STUDENTS
NEED STRONG CONNECTIVITY AND WE
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT IS
BEING DONE ON BEHALF. WITH YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE ON THE LINE
THAT LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE FIFTY SIX. WE DO HAVE
BOWLERS WHO SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK WITH REGARD TO
THIS BILL. BUT I'LL GO TO LINE
AT ONE OH ONE. COME ON A LOT OF
CARE NUMBERS CAROLINE. IN
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR
LONDON BREED IN OPPOSITION
MONEY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE THIRTY FIVE. YOU MAY
NOT KILL PEOPLE THANK YOU.
REALIGNMENT THE- I'M SORRY IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE ON SB FIVE
FIFTY SIX LINE ONE TWELVE. HI
THIS IS RYAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING CORRUPTS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY BUT STOCKTON
GLENDALE FLORIDA BEACH AND THE
TOWN OF TRUCKEE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE THIRTY
ONE. HUESO OF ON BEHALF OF
CROWN CASTLE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. OR LOSE NINE
FORTY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS
ANTHONY TESTS- WITH THE
COMMUNICATIONS OF WILL WORK
WORKERS OF AMERICA LOCAL NINETY
FIVE TEN IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
SB. FIVE SIX. THANK YOU LINE
ONE TWENTY FOR A- GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JUSTIN I ON BEHALF OF
THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND WE ARE SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FINE.
TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
CRISPO CAMP BUT COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA LOCAL NINETY
FIVE ELEVEN IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO FIVE FIVE SIX.
KILL LINE. FORTY HELLO THIS OF
DESPERADO FROM THE W. A LOCAL
NINE FIVE ONE NINE IN SAN DIEGO
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THAT SB
FIVE THANKS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FINE SIXTY ONE. HI MY NAME
IS BILL STILL HAD A WITH THE W.
A LOCAL NINE FOUR ONE THREE AND
I OPPOSE SB FIVE FIVE SIX THANK
YOU. LINE. THIRTY SEVEN. HELLO
THIS IS SCOTT TURNER STREET AT
THE WAY COMMUNICATION WORKERS
OF AMERICA DISTRICT DYNATRON
NOT THE BASEMENT FIVE FIVE DAY.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS JONATHAN AARON
BELL ON BEHALF OF CTIA THE
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE ONE FORTY HILL.
HELLO THIS IS SIDNEY ****
CALLING WITH OF SAFE TECH FOR
SANTA ROSA AND MANY OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU. LINE.
ONE FORTY ONE. HI MY NAME IS
JODY NELSON CALLING FOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR STATE
TECHNOLOGY AS WELL AS SEVENTEEN
OTHER GROUPS INCLUDING CLEANING
AMERICANS FOR RESPONSIBLE.
TECHNOLOGY CALIFORNIA BRAIN
TUMOR BUT ASIAN ALLIANCE OF
NURSES FOR HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT
CENTER FOR DEMOCRATIC RIGHT
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFE FAMILY.
AND MANY OTHERS OPPOSING ITSELF
THANK YOU. LINE. EIGHTY FIVE.
ONE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE'RE GONNA MOVE BONTA
LINE FIFTY KILL. DARREN
WESTMORE CW A LOCAL NINE FOUR
TWO THREE STRONGLY OPPOSE. LINE.
FORTY TWO. YES MY NAME IN THE
LOBBY OF BOTH OF OUR I AM A
LEGISLATIVE AND POLITICAL
DIRECTOR FOR CITY REALLY LOCAL
NINETY FOUR TWENTY ONE. LONGLEY
OPPOSED. LINE. SIXTY THANK YOU
ARE NOT COMPLETE YOUR
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB. FIVE NINE.
LINE ONE SEVENTEEN. HELLO HELLO
MARKETS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
CHAMBER MY NAME IS CHERYL DR
CHERYL SHIRE AND I AM
REPRESENTING MARIN FREEDOM
RISING THERE'S FIVE HUNDRED OF
US AND I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
FIVE FIVE SIX. THANK YOU LINE.
ONE TWENTY FOUR. MORNING
LORRAINE- MY NAME IS LIBERTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FIVE
FIVE SIX YOU GUYS COULD ALSO
BRING COUNTY CARE THANK YOU.
YOU WALK ON LINE BY SEVENTY
ONE. JENNIFER KENNEDY L. A.
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE. LINE
ONE FIFTY. CATHERINE DIED
REPRESENTING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH TRUST POSITIONS FOR SAFE
TECHNOLOGY NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF ENVIRONMENTAL MEDICINE
CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
CALIFORNIANS TO PROVIDE
DIVERSITY COMMUNITY HEARING
FAMILIES ADVOCATING FOR
CHEMICAL IN SAINT COCCYX SIXTY-
SENATE DEMOCRATIC AN
ENVIRONMENTAL RIGHT THE
ECOLOGICAL OPTIONS NETWORK
GRASSROOTS ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION. AND THE CALIFORNIA
BRAIN TUMOR ASSOCIATION
STRONGLY OPPOSE. BLIND ONE THE
BILL. STRONG HAPPEN. TO YEAR
OLD- WE HAVE AN IDEA OF WHAT-
BIRTHDAY- IN OPPOSITION TO THE
PIPELINE THANK YOU. LEVINE.
FORTY SURE HE'S. LINE EIGHTY
ONE. GOOD MORNING LET'S SORRY
SIMPLE THAT A CONTRACTOR FOR C.
W. A. DISTRICT NINE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO IT SB FIVE FIVE SIX
THANK YOU. BY. FIFTY FIVE. FIVE
YOUR MIND IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CLEO CABRAL THE C. W. A. NINE
FOUR ZERO EIGHT AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB. FIVE FIVE SIX. LINE.
EIGHTY FIVE. MY NAME S MARK
LET HERNANDEZ AND I IN THE
NETHERLANDS HE W. A LOCAL NINE
FOUR ONE THREE I OPPOSE SB FIVE
FIVE SIX. LINE. THIRTY SEVEN.
MY NAME IS JANET DEAL DONE WITH
STATE OF THE WAY COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA EIGHT EIGHT
NINE AND I VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE
THE SPELL. YOU CAN FIND ONE
FIFTY SEVEN. DANIEL GOOD
TERRACE ON BEHALF OF TURN THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK IN
OPPOSITION. LINE. ONE THIRTY
FIVE. MADAM CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE WHO IS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBERS I SEE NOBODY GETTING
UP TO SPEAK WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF.
MILLIE'S AVAILABLE. LTZ
ESTIMATES NO FISCAL IMPACT FROM
THIS BILL THANK YOU. I'M MISTER
DIED IT APPEARS SOME VERY LATE
OPPOSITION IT SAID IT'S I FIND
IT VERY DISTURBING THAT- THERE
IS A LOT OF ORGANIZING
OBVIOUSLY FOR PEOPLE TO CALL IN
ON THIS LATE OPPOSITION THAT I
KNEW NOTHING ABOUT SO PERHAPS A
REFLECTION OF THE PEOPLE
REPRESENTING YOU. DO YOU THE-
AS YOU ARE- I'VE GONE THROUGH
ALL THE COMMITTEES AND THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY AND
THEY'VE ASKED ME TIME AND TIME
AGAIN TO BE WITH CITIES- COUNTY
SUBURB- AND WE BROUGHT A LOT OF
PEOPLE TOGETHER WITH YOU
MEMBERS WE'VE TAKEN WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK THIS- SO
CERTAINLY SIT DOWN WITH ANYBODY
WANTS TO TALK ABOUT THIS BILL
THANK YOU I REALLY SUGGEST
SITTING DOWN AT LEAST WITH- THE
UNION OBVIOUSLY THAT THAT
REPRESENTS WORKERS IN THIS
FIELD- BEFORE TAKING IT OUT OF
THIS RISING ALL THIS WOULD DO
IS GIVE A MORE WORK I WOULD
THINK THAT- I WILL HANG OUT
WITH THEM I APPRECIATE THAT BE
HAPPY TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU AND
THEM IF POSSIBLE. ALRIGHT WITH
THAT ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. CONCERNS ALL RIGHT-
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
WITH MR VOEPEL VOTING NOW. I'M
SORRY MR ALI I COULDN'T NOT MR
VOEPEL EXPLODING YES MISS DOLLY
IS VOTING NOW I'M SORRY.
EVERYTHING LINED UP WEIRD THANK
YOU SENATOR ABOUT SPENCER MASS
COMING AT ALL- I THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO PRESENT YOUR TWO BILLS
PLUS ONE FOR MR ARCHULETA IS
THAT CORRECT. OKAY WE WILL
BEGIN WITH SB THREE TWENTY
THREE. ENJOY THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND BY
DOCTOR QUIRK- AND I THINK- YOU
MAY PROCEED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR- I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB THREE TWENTY THREE
IT WOULD CREATE A HUNDRED.
TWENTY DAY STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR CLAIMS AGAINST
WATER AND SEWER AGENCY RATE
SETTINGS. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
BILL WITH THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS WHICH CLARIFIED THE
START DATE OF THE ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DAY TIMELINE- THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
AYE VOTE. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
IS CHRIS ANDERSON FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES THANK YOU WILL GO TO
THE WITNESS. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS PRETENDERS
AND I'LL BE HAPPY FOR CREATION
THE CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
WERE THE PROUD SPONSOR OF SB
THREE TWO THREE- FIRST JUST
WHEN I THINK THEY COMMITTEE
STAFFER THE KIND MADE DEVOTED
PORTION OF HER FROM THE BELL.
SOUTH LIKE TO THANK SENATOR COP
BY OUR CABALLERO BURKE. AND HER
STAFF FOR THEIR DILIGENT WORK
ON THE BILL- THE BILL'S BEEN
REFERRED TO PROCREATION
COMMITTEE BECAUSE OF A RETURN
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD REQUIRE
PUBLIC AGENCIES TO INCLUDE
INFORMATION ABOUT A STATUE
LIMITATIONS AND I NOTICED THAT.
PRIOR TO- TEND TO THE PUBLIC
PRIOR TO THE ADOPTION OF THE
NEW RATE STRUCTURE. HE NOTICED
WILL SERVE. TO INFORM CUSTOMERS
OF THEIR RIGHTS IMPORTANTLY THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IDENTIFIED
THAT THIS MANDATE. WOULD RESULT
IN LITTLE ANY COSTS- IN SHORT
WE BELIEVE THE BILL STRIKES A
BALANCE BETWEEN PROTECTING THE
RIGHTS RATE PAYERS AND ALLOWING
THE- PUBLIC WATER AND SEWER
AGENCIES TO AVOID. UNNECESSARY
FINANCIAL UNCERTAINTY FOR THESE.
REASONS REQUEST- I THOUGHT
THANK YOU. HE WILL GO TO- PHONE
MY ANY. IN SUPPORT OR ARE. TO
SB THREE TWENTY THREE. THOSE OF
YOU WHO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY TO GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS FROM
THE ASSEMBLY SHOCK ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AT.
THAT'S NOT NOT PART. THANK ONE
NINETEEN THANK YOU. WINE. ONE
FORTY THREE. THANK YOU MA'AM
CHEN MEMBER FROST BUCKLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. LINE.
ONE FORTY FIVE. HELLO OKAY. ONE
IS OPEN ALL. HELLO BY ONE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU. ALLEN ON BEHALF OF BARBER
NEMCO IN THE NAPA COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION AND WE SUPPORT SB
FIVE FIVE SIX THANK YOU. FIND
ONE THIRTY FIVE. ANDREA HAD
OPPOSED. THANK YOU BYE AND. ONE
SEVENTY SIX. HI GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GLENN
FARRELL WITH THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT. FIND ONE TWENTY FOUR.
PLEASE CALL THAT PARTLY WHAT
ONE TWENTY FORTY ONE SOMETHING.
HELLO THANK YOU LIBERTY
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB THREE TWO
THREE THANK YOUNG. THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THAT AS
CHAMBERS I SEE NOBODY AT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU- WITH. THIS BILL AND NOTE
THIS. LEVEL FISCAL IN THIS BILL
WILL NOT IMPOSE REIMBURSABLE
STATE MANDATED COSTS BECAUSE WE
ESTIMATE A LOCAL AGENCY- HAVING
COSTS AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL
WOULD HAVE COST LESS THAN ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE
NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YA I
VOTE THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT
WITHIN A ROLL CALL WITH MISTER
ALI NOT VOTING NEXT WE HAVE SB
SEVEN FOURTEEN IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND
BY DOCTOR CORK. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- PLEASED TO PRESENT SB
SEVEN FOURTEEN WHICH WOULD
AMEND THE ELECTION CODE TO
ALLOW ASPIRING CITIZENS SUCH AS
DREAMERS TO BE ELECTED. TO A-DEMOCRATIC COUNTY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE- THE BILL WILL
ELIMINATE SYSTEMATIC BARRIERS
THAT PREVENT IMMIGRANTS TO HAVE
A VOICE WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IN THEIR COMMUNITY. LAST
ONE- THERE SB SEVEN FOURTEEN
WOULD MAKE MINOR CHANGES TO THE
DUTIES OF THE COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS AND THERE FOR THE
COSTS ARE ANTICIPATED TO BE
OBSERVABLE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU AND WE'LL GO
TO THE WITNESS CARLOS- I'LL
KALRA ON THE LINE. IT'S CARLOS
THERE. HE MAY NOT BE ON THE
LINE HE DID NOT CONFIRM WITH
OUR OFFICE THAT HE WOULD OKAY
BE ABLE TO MAKE IT ALL RIGHT
THAT'S FINE WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES IS THERE ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB.
SEVEN FOURTEEN. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN THERE-
PRESS. ONE ZERO. ONE AND ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AS IN SUPPORT BUT NOT IN
OPPOSITION NO WE HAVE NO. YOU
HAVE TO PRE REGISTER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER COLORS
FLYING. SEVENTY ONE. JENNIFER
KENNEDY L. A. COUNTY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN FOURTEEN.
WELL BLIND. ONE TWENTY FOUR.
HELLO THIS IS LIBERTY STRONG
OPPOSITION SB. SEVEN FOURTEEN.
FIND ONE TWENTY FIVE MY SEAT
YEAH I'M ON A PRECISION
OBVIOUSLY SINCE THANK YOU. NINE
ONE SIX THREE THREE ONE ONE SIX
THREE ONE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS SUE O'CONNOR IN MADERA
COUNTY AT NINE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL. AND
WE DO HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
PERSON WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LINE ONE EIGHTY. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ALEX TOWARDS
SPEAKING IN MY ROLE AS AN
ELECTED- DELEGATE FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON WHO'S
QUEUED UP JUST A MOMENT. REALLY
GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY THREE.
ONE ONE SEVENTY THREE THE LINES
NOW OPEN. THERE IS NO ONE OUT
TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU SEEN NOBODY-
MOVING TO THE MICROPHONE IN THE
CHAMBERS WILL GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT INDICATES THE. IN
FACT THE CASE THIS BILL WOULD
NOT CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE AS THE COST TO COUNTY
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO ACCEPT
AND PRESERVE DECLARATIONS OF
ELIGIBILITY FROM CANDIDATES
WOULD LIKELY BE LESS THAN ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY THANK
YOU. THANK YOUNG. AND BRING IT
BACK I SEE NO QUESTIONS- THANK
YOU FOR CARRYING THIS BILL IF
I'M NOT ALREADY I'D LIKE TO BE
A CO AUTHOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE IN THANK YOU AND WE
WILL MAKE SURE WE- CAN ADD
THAT. THANK YOU CHECK IT OUT ON
A B. ROLL CALL. AND YOU'RE
GONNA SEE PRESIDENT SB FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF MR
ARCHULETA- IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND BY A-
DOCTOR CORK. YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
ARCHULETA. GIVE ME GREAT
PLEASURE TO PRESENT SB FORTY
FOUR REGARDING LICENSE PLUMBING
CONTRACTOR REPAIR EXEMPTIONS.
WHICH THE BILL CLARIFIES THAT A
LICENSED PLUMBING CONTRACTOR
CAN MAKE REPAIRS. TO A SEWER
LATERAL IT THEY HAVE INSPECTED.
EVEN IF THEY ARE THE KIND OF.
COMPANY HAS PERFORMED A HOME
HOME INSPECTION ON THE PROP
PROP PROPERTY. CURRENTLY IS
CONSIDERED UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICE. PRACTICE FOR A
PLUMBING CONTRACTOR TO DO BOTH.
OF THESE BUT- SB. FORTY FOUR
CORRECT THE PROBLEM AND ALLOWS
CONSUMER MORE CHOATE TRACES THE
BILL HAS LITTLE TO NO COST TO
THE STATE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU WE'LL GO TO PHONE LINES
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF MR GILLETTE AS SB.
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR. ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO. MADAM
CHAIR I BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE
PERSON WHO MAY HAVE WANT TO
SPEAK FOR THE PREVIOUS BILL.
I'M SORRY THE PREVIOUS BILLS
BEEN DISPENSED OF. THERE IS
NOTHING ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK I'M SORRY I
MISUNDERSTOOD ON CALL ALL
RIGHT- I SEE NOBODY IN THE
CHAMBERS- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
INDICATES NO FISCAL IMPACT FROM
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU I
SEE NOBODY WITH QUESTIONS- THAT
BILL GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU VENTURE. I CENTER DID
US ALL. YOU'LL BE PRESENTING.
SB SEVEN HUNDRED IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND
BY DOCTOR CORK. YOU MAY PROCEED
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR GOOD
TO SEE YOU- THANKYOU OF SB
SEVEN HUNDRED- IS WITH REGARDS
TO ENSURING MISCLASSIFIED PORT
TRUCK DRIVERS HAVE ACCESS TO
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS THEY'RE ENTITLED TO
DURING THE PANDEMIC IT BECAME
CLEAR YOU AYE BENEFITS WERE THE
ONLY LIFELINE FOR MOST WORKERS-
BUT YET AS AMOUNT OF CARGO IN
THE PORTS DROP MANY DRIVERS
FOUND THEMSELVES OUT OF WORK
WHEN THEY APPLIED FOR BENEFITS
THEY WERE UNFAIRLY DENIED AT
THAT INITIAL LEVEL SB SEVEN
HUNDRED SIMPLY DIRECTS ET DE TO
COMPLY WITH TWO KEY DECISIONS.
OF THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE APPEALS BOARD THAT
RIGHTFULLY FONG DRIVERS TO BE
EMPLOYEES AND THE TRUCKING
COMPANY TO BE THE EMPLOYER MUST
PAY YOU I TAXES COST OF DOING
THIS IS MINOR AND ABSORB
OBSERVABLE. I HAVE ONE WITNESS
TODAY KAELIN VEGA. BUT WE DON'T
HAVE YOU DOWN HAVING A WITH S.
OKAY MR RESO SO WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO THE PHONE LINES JUST
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO SB. SEVEN HUNDRED. AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE OF. PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. GOING TO GO TO
LINE SEVENTY ONE YOUR AND IT'S
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JENNIFER
KENNEDY L. A. COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU BYE THE.
ONE GOOD MORNING CANNABIS
CRYSTAL CAN ALSO BE HAPPY
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU. ONE
ONE SEVENTY FOUR. MADAM CHAIR
NUMBER KATE AND DATA ON BEHALF
OF SUPPORT DIVISION AT THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
TEAMSTERS. SB SEVEN HUNDRED
THIS BILL WILL REDUCE STATE
COSTS BY A- A LIVING EIGHTEEN
CAITLYN THANK TO HELP TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WELL LINE
ONE TWENTY FOUR. HELLO THIS IS
LIBERTY. I AM IN OPPOSITION- SB
SEVEN HUNDRED. THANK YOU. LINE.
ONE EIGHTY FIVE. JOSHUA COLEMAN
FROM ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA NINE
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU FOR FUTURE
REFERENCE I'VE NOTICED A COUPLE
OF THE LOOKS OF CONFUSION ON
THIS DYESS- THE WOMAN WHO IS
OPPOSING THE BILL'S- SAME
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT YOUR FROM THE
OLD COUNTY LOS ANGELES BECAUSE
I THINK. THERE'S SOME EOPLE
WHO ARE BEING CONFUSED THAT YOU
REPRESENT THE COUNTY OF LA THAT
IS TWO VERY DIFFERENT THINGS SO
IF YOU. READ REPRESENT AN
ORGANIZATION YOU JUST NEED TO
SAY THE ORGANIZATION'S NAME. IF
YOU ARE FROM AN AREA- PLEASE
STATE YOUR FROM THE AREA WE
DON'T WANT PEOPLE- CONFUSED
ABOUT WHO THE OPPOSITION IS- I
THOUGHT THE CONFUSION OVER
HERE. AS IT NOBODY I THINK IN
THE- CHAMBERS WANTS TO SPEAK
WILL GO AHEAD AND TAKE IT TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
BINANCE HAS NO POSITION. EITHER
AT ALL COSTS. THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU BRING IN A BATH I SEE
NO COMMENTS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AS WE ARE BOTH THANK YOU
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL. THANK YOU SENATOR.
SENATOR PORTANTINO GLAD WE WERE
ABLE TO WORK THIS OUT I'M SORRY
IT WASN'T NOTICED THIS WAY BUT
MR. PORTANTINO IS GOING TO
PRESENT. ON SB FORKS- IT HAD IS
AN URGENCY MATTER SO THAT.
WE'RE WE'RE MAKING THAT UNUSUAL
RECOMMENDATION- IT HAS A LOW
COST BUT WE ARE AND MAKING A
RECOMMENDATION GOES DIRECTLY TO
THE FLOOR NOT ON SUSPENSE WITH
THAT- YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL AS IT
ADDRESSES STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
AS YOU KNOW. OUR STUDENTS ARE
RETURNING TO SCHOOL THIS MONTH.
MENTAL HEALTH IS ON THE TOP ON
THE MIND OF OBVIOUSLY OF THE
STUDENTS THEMSELVES THEIR
PARENTS TEACHERS SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS. CALIFORNIANS IN
THE MIDST OF A BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CRISIS EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC. THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
STUDENTS. TO STAY HOME FROM
SCHOOL AS AN APPROVED ABSENCE
WITH A MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER.
IMAGINE BEING A TEENAGER. HOME
WITH STRESS ANXIETY BIPOLAR.
AND WONDERING IF YOU'RE
ABSENCES APPROVED- THE COST
THAN THAT AS THEY NOW SUS SAID.
ACTUALLY COULD HAVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE AND THEN IT ALSO
SEEKS TO HAVE CVD BEST
PRACTICES TO IDENTIFY A YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID
COMPONENT. AND I'LL LEAVE YOU
WITH ONE ANECDOTE I WAS DOING
AN EDITORIAL BOARD INTERVIEW IN
ONE OF THE EDITOR SAID TO ME
WHAT HAPPENS IF A PARENT LIES
ABOUT THEIR KID HAVING A MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDER. AND I SAID WE
DON'T ASK THAT QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER YOUR KID HAS A COLD OR
SPRAINED ANKLE WHY WOULD YOU
ASSUME THEY WOULD BE LYING
ABOUT A MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER
AND I SAID THE FACT THAT YOU
ASK THE QUESTION. UNDERSCORES
WHY WE NEED TO DE STIGMATIZE
MENTAL HEALTH- THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY A HOST OF
ORGANIZATIONS THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL COMMITTEE BIGELOW
AGENCIES. SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION LADY
GAGA'S BORN THIS WAY FOUNDATION
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
NEXT YEAR IN CALIFORNIA. AND
IMPORTANTLY THE VOICES OF
STUDENTS INCLUDING CHEN UP
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL COUNCILS AND
CALIFORNIA'S CALIFORNIA STUDENT
BOARD MEMBERS I KNOW WE HAVE A
WITNESS ONLINE AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SHARE THIS IMPORTANT BILL
IS MOVING MOVE THE BILL. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY DR PARK IN A
SECOND BY MISCREANTS THANK YOU
WILL GO AHEAD AND GO. TO THE
PHONE LINES YOU SAID YOU HAVE A-
WITNESS WILL GO THERE FORCED.
WE SHOULD HAVE. WON IF THERE'S
NO WHEN AS WILL GO HEAD TO
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES. MANAGER WITH
WHAT'S THE NAME OF THE WITNESS.
I THINK IT'S SOMEBODY FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE NOT SURE THIS WAS A LAST
MINUTE ADDITION I'M SORRY. SO-
IF SHE SHOWS UP OR SHEER HE
SHOWS UP DURING THE NORMAL
THINGS WILL LET THEM SPEAK. I'M
GOING TO GO TO LINE UP. ONE
NINETY. NUMBER THIRTY FORTY
DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF THE
THIRTIETH SANTA MONICA
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN THANK YOU
THANK YOUNG. WHY. EIGHTY NINE.
GOOD MORNING HELLO HELLO THEY
HAVE A SECTION CALIFORNIA
PRACTICAL BONKERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOUNG. LINE. ONE SIX. THE
MORNING TO RECOMMEND THEY HAVE
TO BE A TEACHER CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS IN
SUPPORT OF SB FUNCTIONAL THANK
YOU. LINE WHAT THE SEX. GOOD
MORNING THIS AGREEMENT CHECK
FROM DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA I AM THE WHAT NEEDS
ARE MET I PERSONALLY. I WAS A
WITNESS MADAM CHAIR IT APPEARS
WE FOUND OUR WAY OKAY YES
ABSOLUTELY I'M SORRY I'M HAVING
A HARD TIME HEARING THERE'S A
LOT GOING ON UP HERE. I'M YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME OKAY.
YES. I WILL PROCEED GOOD
MORNING THAT'S CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KINDA CHUCK AND I AM A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I
STUDENTS RETURN TO SCHOOL THIS
MONTH MENTAL HEALTH IS TOP O
MIND FOR MANY FAMILIES TEACHERS
AND SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE MIDST OF
THE USE HEALTH EXACERBATED BY
THE COCA NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
WARNING WAS AND IN SOME
DISTRICTS IS THE BEST SOLUTION
TO EDUCATING YOUTH DURING THE
PANDEMIC HOWEVER WE HAVE
QUICKLY DETERMINED THAT THE
IMPACT OF DISTANCE EDUCATION IS
INCREASED ISOLATION AND
DISENGAGEMENT AND AGGRESSION
FROM ARE AMONG AND AMONG OTHER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONCERNS ARE
AT. AN ALL TIME HIGH. THE NEW
YORK THE OF AND HE SERVICES.
NEARLY ONE IN THREE CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS SURVEYED
REPORTED FEELING SAD OR
HOPELESS ALMOST EVERY DAY FOR
TWO OR MORE WEEKS IN A ROW.
NEARLY ONE IN FIVE REPORT THAT
THEY HAVE FIERCELY CONSIDERED
SUICIDE. SIDE IS THE SECOND
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG
PEOPLE AGE TEN TO THIRTY FOUR.
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF ARE
ON THE FRONT LINES OF THESE
CRISES AND SHOULD BE TRAINED TO
IDENTIFY AND HOPE STUDENTS WHO
ARE SUFFERING. RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT THE FEAR PEOPLE GET HELP
FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
USE CONCERNS THE MORE LIKELY
THEY ARE TO HAVE TALK ABOUT COM.
YOU KNOW THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE
TRANSITIONING TO IMPRESS THE
LEARNING TEACHERS ARE
ENCOUNTERING. ISSUES RESULTING
FROM MOTION EFFECT OF THE
PANDEMIC ON THEIR STUDENTS. SB
FOURTEEN HELP ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM. FIRST INSURANCE THAT
CAN HAPPEN TO BE HERE FOR
HEALTH CONCERNS ARE TREATED THE
SAME AS EXCUSED ABSENCES FOR
PHYSICAL HEALTH CONCERNS YOU
HAVE TWENTY MORE SECONDS
EXPLAINED EXCUSE ABSENCES. SB
FOURTEEN REQUIRED. RECOMMEND
BEST PRACTICES AND EVIDENCE
BASED MENTAL HEALTH TRAINING.
FOR SCHOOL SAID DRUG USE BE
ABLE HEALTH INCLUDING TRAINING
FOR TEACHERS STAFF AND
STUDENTS. AND HOW TO RECOGNIZE
A PURPLISH BOND AND SEEK HELP
FOR MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY A
COALITION OF PEOPLE HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND MENTAL HEALTH
ADVOCATES. WHO HAVE TANK YOU
WORKED ILLUSTRATE THEIR NEEDS
THANK YOU YOUR TIME IS UP IRAQI
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EYES
CLOSED THANK YOU THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD AND WILL TAKE PEOPLE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION-
CONTINUING TO TESTIFY OR NOT
TESTIFY REGISTER. THEIR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN.
DO WE HAVE ANY MORE COLORS
OPERATOR ALL. YEAH YES MADAM
CHAIR WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE.
ONE FIFTEEN. FIND ONE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN A MOVE ON
THE LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR. HELLO
LIBERTARIANS I'M IN OPPOSITION
TO SB. FOURTEEN THANK YOU LINE
TO- ONE. HELLO THIS IS SHALL WE
DO VERY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACCESS COALITION AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE. TWO OH FOUR. GOOD MORNING
THEN AFTER LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OPPOSITION ONCE THANK YOU THANK
YOU FINE THIRTY NINE. THE
MORNING. DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB. FOURTEEN WINDS. TWO
HUNDRED. GOOD MORNING FINALLY
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHIND AGING. I'LL
ANSWER THE BELL THANK YOU. LINE.
TWO OH FIVE. MADAM CHAIR TONY
TO KERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE LOOK FORWARD TO REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN WITH
SOME- DOUBLE JOINING LANGUAGE
WITH AB THREE ZERO NINE AS WELL
AS FUNDING LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOUNG. BECAUSE OF WHICH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO DISPEL PLEASE
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE BELIEVE THAT SOME OF YOU MAY
HAVE BEEN MOVED YOURSELF BY
ACCIDENT FROM THE- FROM THE
QUEUE. PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO. GOING TO GO TO LINE. ONE
FIFTEEN. HI MY NAME IS MARYLAND
HELPED. MY NAME IS CAROL
SHELTON FROM VENTURA COUNTY AND
I SUPPORT AT THE FOURTEENTH.
FIND. ONE NINETY SEVEN. MEDIA
BORN REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION WE'RE IN
SUPPORT. LINE. ONE SIXTY THREE.
MY NAME IS SUE O'CONNOR IN
MADERA COUNTY I SUPPORT SB
FOURTEEN BUT I AM VERY CONFUSED
BY THE LACK. OF KNOWLEDGE AND-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR LITTLE
CROSS RIVER ROAD MADAM CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
PARDON ME WE DO HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON FINDS SEVENTY
ONE. GOOD MORNING SCHERING
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION IT'S JENNIFER
KENNEDY I'M A RESIDENT OF L. A.
COUNTY AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELL THAT IS PART IN FINANCE
NOW. FINANCE HAS NO POSITION
NOT OF ANY COSTA COUNTY AND
AFFORDABLE. AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT THIS POLL RESULTS IN
INCREASED PEOPLE ABSENCES AND A
LOSS OF FUNDING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. THIS BILL COULD RESULT
IN PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COST SAVINGS
RANGING FROM THE TNS OF
THOUSANDS TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. AT THE
STATE LEVEL. IT IS. HOW DID YOU
DO THAT AS A RESULT FROM THIS
BILL BELL. AND ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL THE RESULT IN A
MINIMAL- PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND REIMBURSABLE
STATE MANDATE COST. TO THE
EXTENT THAT ELEAZAR SEE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
PROCESSING OF ABSENCES RELATED
TO MENTAL OR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
THANK YOU. YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE MEMBERS I THINK
MISTER BRIAN HAD A QUESTION
RIGHT NO LONGER HAS A QUESTION
ALL RIGHT. I SEE NO DISCUSSION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST
WANNA GIVE A SHOUT OUT AGAIN
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AGENCIES AND ALL OF THE
COALITION BEHIND THE BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU
SENATOR. AND I AM SORRY I DO
NOT KNOW WHO IS THE NEXT.
MISTER MCGUIRE YOU ARE
PRESENTING FOR MISS ATKINS- ON
S. B. NINE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND
BY DOCTOR QUIRK. YOU MAY
PROCEED I DON'T CARE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME I KNOW
IT'S A BUSY DAY FOR EACH OF YOU
IN MISTER VICE CHAIR THANK YOU
AGAIN AT UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE IS A DO PASS
ECOMMENDATION I'LL STREAMLINED
THE PRESENTATION HERE. BOTTOM
LINE IS YOU ALL KNOW- FOR MANY
OF YOU THIS IS GONNA LOOK
SIMILAR TO A BILL THAT THE PRO
TIM AUTHORED LAST SESSION WHICH
WAS O. S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY- AND
WE TOOK A GOOD DEAL THAT MET
THE FATE OF A HARD DEADLINE.
AND AFTER LISTENING TO FEEDBACK
THAT IT IS BEING IMPROVED IN
THAT HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MAIN
GOALS AT FOR THE PROTEIN IS TO
IMPROVE THIS BILL I'D LIKE TO.
JUST FOCUS QUICKLY ON TO RECENT
CHANGES THAT IS BEFORE YOU
TODAY OUR UNDERSTANDING THIS IS
A FISCAL COMMITTEE BECAUSE THE
PROTEIN LISTEN TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS IN POLICY COMMITTEE TO
BE TO MAKE THESE CHANGES NUMBER
ONE RECENT AMENDMENT
STRENGTHENED THE OWNER
OCCUPANCY PROVISION CURRENTLY
IN THE BILL BY MAKING IT A
STATEWIDE REQUIREMENT TO ENSURE
THAT HOMEOWNERS. BENEFIT FROM
THESE NEW HOUSING OPTIONS NOT
CORPORATE INVESTORS. NUMBER
TWO. SECOND SB NINE NOW ALLOWS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DENY A
PROPOSED HOUSING DEVELOPMENT OR
A LOT SLIT. IF THE BUILDING
OFFICIAL IN THE CITY OR COUNTY
MAKES A FINDING THAT THERE IS
AN ADVERSE IMPACT ON PUBLIC
HEALTH OR SAFETY THAT CAN'T BE
MITIGATED. QUICK EXAMPLE OF HOW
THAT WOULD WORK. SO WE TOOK
WHAT WAS ALREADY A PROCESS IN
LAW. A STANDARD APPROVED THAT'S
CURRENTLY IN THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. AN INDEBTED
IT IN SB NINE. SO FOR EXAMPLE.
IF A BUILDING OFFICIAL. IN A
CITY OR COUNTY. FINDS THAT A
HOMEOWNER CAN'T MITIGATE FOR
FIRE RISK. THEN THAT
DEVELOPMENT. CAN BE STOPPED IN
TONIGHT. SAME THING IF THERE
ARE TOXIC SUBSTANCES ON THE
SITE SAME THING IF THE
HOMEOWNERS TRYING TO DEVELOP
FOR EXAMPLE ON IT TOO STEEP A
SLOPE. I WANT TO POINT OUT ON
THE FISCAL SIDE THAT. THE PRO
TEAM IN THE SPEAKER HAVE BEEN
WORKING TOGETHER IN VERY
GRATEFUL IN REGARD TO THE
INVESTMENTS OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE GOVERNOR HAD MADE THIS
YEAR IN REGARDS TO COMBATING
HOUSING CRISIS AND THAT'S GONNA
INCLUDE A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE MILLION. TO HELP LOW INCOME
FIRST TIME HOMEBUYERS ANY
EIGHTY YOU FINANCING FOR THE
FIRST TIME TO BE A TO GET
EIGHTEEN IS DEPLOYED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THIS BILL CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE REAL
PROGRESSIVE AND POSITIVE CHANGE
IN STRENGTH IN THE FABRIC OF
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS WITH EQUITY
INCLUSIVITY. IS WELLS
AFFORDABILITY AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND CHAIR I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON BEHALF OF.
AMERICANS WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
PHONE LINES I DO WANT SINCE WE
HAVE THREE WITNESSES BEGAN THE
STRONG SUPPORT WHEN IN
OPPOSITION. I DO WANNA REMIND
WITNESSES AT THIS POINT THAT
THIS IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE SO
THE ONLY THING YOU ARE TO SPEAK
TOWARDS IS THE FISCAL I AM NOT
GOING TO SO IF YOU START VERY
OFTEN A POLICY. WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO STOP YOU YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES AND WE WILL START WITH-
LAUREN. THE DIFFERENCE YEAH
EAST ON SHOWS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AREN'T ABLE
ONE PAIR REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND WE'RE
VERY PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB
NINE. THE ABILITY TO RENT OR
OWN A HOME CONTINUES TO BE AN
ONGOING CHALLENGE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA FURTHER EXACERBATED
BY THE PANDEMIC. UNDER CURRENT
LAW MAJORITY OF RESIDENTIAL
AREAS CAN ONLY BE USED FOR
SINGLE DWELLING AND THAT'S
PLYMOUTH HOUSING SUPPLY
INCLUDES LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
MINORITY COMMUNITIES. WITH HOME
PRICES STEADILY RISING DUE TO
LIMITED SUPPLY STEMMING FROM
INCREASED COST OF BUILDING
MATERIAL LABOR SHORTAGES AND
REGULATORY CONSTRAINTS.
CALIFORNIA MATTHEW MORE EXPAND
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES. SB NINE
CREATED BY RIGHT MINISTERIAL
PROCESS FOR THE CREATION OF TWO
HOMES AND A SINGLE FAMILY LOTS
IT ALSO ABOUT PERSONAL MAPS TO
CREATE TWO LOTS FROM ONE. TO
LIVE WITH YOU UNITS EACH EIGHTY
LAW ALREADY ALLOWS UP TO THREE
UNITS A LOT OF THIS IS AN AND
INCREMENTAL. CHANGE THAT THE
KEY. APART FROM THAT. WERE
ALLOWS HOMES BE FOR. THIS WILL
HELP HOME ON OP. NOT AVAILABLE
UNDER OTHER HOUSING PRODUCTION
BUILD. DEVELOPMENT UNDER SB
NINE WOULD BE PRIVATELY FUNDED
AND WOULD NOT REQUIRE DIRECT
EIGHT. EIGHT FUNDING INCREASES
TO INCREASE HOUSING COMPLY
ALLOWING MORE UNITS FOR
EXISTING LAW WILL ALSO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR JURISDICTIONS TO
COMPLY WITH NEW ARENA MANDATE.
AND IT ALSO PROVIDES FOR THE
PRESUMPTION FORGET OPTION OF
NEW ORDINANCES WHICH WILL HELP
REDUCE COSTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS JOKES ACTUALLY THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. FINALLY
SB NINE WILL COULD INCREASE
HOUSING OPTIONS AND SINGLE
FAMILY FOUND TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES MORE INCLUSIVE ALL
THIS WITHOUT MAJOR FINANCIAL
IMPACT THE GENERAL FUND. WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE SENATE.
FOR GREATER HELP ON THE THING
THAT WAS TWO MINUTES AGO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I'M ASKED TO
REST WITNESSES NOW WE HAD A
VERY GOOD THOROUGH EXPLANATION
WHAT THE BILL DOES WE ARE GOING
TO TALK ABOUT THE COST TO THE
STATE THAT IS WHAT- THIS
COMMITTEE IS BASING A DECISION
ON. THE COST TO THE STATES ARE
SECOND WITNESS. IS TAMI NEUMANN
FROM- UNITED WAY AND IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A POINTS ABOUT THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE COST TO
THE STATE THEN WE'RE. GONNA
MOVE ON TO OUR POSITION WHEN AS
THANK YOU. TOM MORNING MADAM
AND SOME MEMBERS GIVE HER HAVE
ME TIME AND IN MANY. WAY
DIRECTOR SUPPORT HEAR YOU LOUD
AND CLEAR WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY BILLION DOLLAR.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GAP HERE IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE KNOW THAT
WE NEED BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SOLUTION. BECAUSE WE CAN'T DO
IT ALONE AND SO WE SUPPORT SB
NINE- AT AS A TOOL ONE TOOL OF
MANY. TO HELP US INCREASE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS.
USING PRIVATE DOLLARS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WELL DONE. WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO- TO THE
OPPOSITION WITNESS. OUR BILL
BRAND OF REDONDO BEACH. ON THE
FISCAL MISTER BRANDT. IS MESSED
AROUND ON THE LINE. OPERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE THERE SHOULD WE GO
TO THE- REGULAR PHONE LINES.
MADAM CHAIR WE ARE SHOWING A
PHONE LINE CONNECTED FOR- MR
BRAND. MR BRAND PLEASE RESPOND
YOUR YOUR PHONE LINE SHOULD BE
OPENS ARE. PARDON ME I SEE
SOMETHING GOING ON HERE JUST A
MOMENT- JUST A MOMENT WE'RE
GOING TO BRING HIM INTO THE
CONFERENCE. I BET YOU COULD NOT
PERFECT. MISTER BRAND MISTER
BROWN YES PARDON ME SORRY THAT
YOU'VE BEEN JOINED TO THE
COMMITTEE CONFERENCE AND YOU'VE
JUST BEEN CALLED UPON TO SPEAK
SIR. CAN I GO AHEAD AND SPEAK
YOU MADE ON THE FISCAL OF THE
BILL. WELL THANK YOU MY NAME IS
BILL GRANT MAYOR OF REDONDO
BEACH SERVED EIGHT YEARS AS A
COUNCIL MEMBER. RECENTLY
REELECTED FOR A SECOND FOUR
YEAR TERM AS MAYOR- FROM A
FISCAL PERSPECTIVE THIS IS
GONNA COST CITIES DRAMATICALLY-
WE'RE- RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS
DOES NOT PAY THE BILLS FOR A
HUGE COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENT AND
A FURTHER SPLIT OUR RESIDENTIAL
LOTS WILL PUT A GREAT FINANCIAL
BURDEN. ON CITIES ALL OVER THE
STATE. THE HOPE YOU'LL TAKE
THAT UNDER CONSIDERATION AT A
MUCH BIGGER SPEECH ABOUT SB
NINE I HOPE YOU'LL VOTE NINE
VOTE NO. BUT UNFORTUNATELY I
GUESS I DON'T GET TO SPEAK TO
FIGHT ABOUT THAT BECAUSE-
YOU'RE ONLY HEARING ABOUT THE
FISCAL IMPACTS TO THE STATE.
WHICH OF COURSE WOULD BE GREAT
BECAUSE MANY OTHER IMPACTS
RELATED TO GENTRIFICATION AND
DISTURBING LOCAL CONTROL OF
OUR- MADE USE. AND IS OWNING IN
IN VARIOUS COMMUNITIES SO- GAP
WITH THAT I'LL JUST SAY THAT
MANY MANY LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS ACROSS ACROSS THE
STATE. SHARE MY CONCERNS NOW
ABOUT THE FISCAL WITH OTHER
ISSUES. AND WILL BE DOING A
STATEWIDE INITIATIVE TO MAKE
HIS OWNING LAND USE A MUNICIPAL
AFFAIR. AND TO SEE THAT
INITIATIVE IT MIMICS EIGHTY
EIGHT SEVEN. WHICH MIGHT COME
BEFORE YOU AND- YOU CAN READ
ABOUT THE INITIATIVE IT
COMMUNITIES FOR CHOICE YES SIR
DOT ONE NOT GONNA WE'RE NOT
GONNA GO INTO. INITIATIVES
HERE- WITH THAT WILL TAKE IT TO
THE PHONE LINES ANYONE EITHER
REGISTERING YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO S. B. NINE YOU
SAY YOUR NAME EITHER YOUR
ORGANIZATION OR WHERE YOU'RE
FROM AND YOUR POSITION. THAT IS
YET FOR SB NINE. WHAT HELLO AND
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LET AND
AGAIN- FOR THIS BILL- PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE. ONE OH TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THANK YOU KNOW
THAT THE TERRORISTS ROSENBLOOM
WITH THE LOS ANGELES BUSINESS
COUNCIL CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE THANK YOU. LINE. FORTY
FOUR. SURELY LOANED OUT.
APOPLECTIC DUBLIN ALLIANCE AND
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB NINE. BY ONE THIRTY
SIX. EILEEN BROKEN COALITION
FOR SAN FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
FIND. SEVENTY FOUR. MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBER WILLIAM
MCCANN BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS AND
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA YIMBY THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANNING
AND URBAN RESEARCH THAT PATIENT
OFTEN AND IT'S FOR HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION. I THINK
BECAUSE- GREENBELT ALLIANCE.
AREA COUNCIL AND FACEBOOK THANK
YOU. TAKE A MOMENT TO REMIND
ALL THE WITNESSES TO PLEASE USE
YOUR MUTE BUTTON- WHEN NOT
CALLED UPON TO SPEAK WHEN YOU
GO TO LINE NINETY TWO. MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS BOB NAYLOR
REPRESENTING FIELD SEVEN
COMPANY AN ORANGE COUNTY BASED
BUSINESS STRONGLY FAVORING.
HOUSING EVERYWHERE THANK YOU
AND THIS BILL. LINE ONE SIXTY
TWO. NINE ONE SIX TWO. JENNIFER
STACK ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS FOR THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS ADOPTED ON
MONDAY STAIRS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB NINE. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
EITHER THANK YOU. LINE. NINETY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING KURT
BLACKBURN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CITIES OF INGLEWOOD AND%
LOCKING UP ON STAGE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LYING. TO
TWENTY SEVEN. WE'VE DONE
NOTHING NOTHING THAT FROM BRENT
WHAT CALIFORNIA CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER AND MEMBER OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR A BETTER BRENT
WHAT IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE TOP. THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
SIXTY THREE. SUE O'CONNOR FROM
MADERA CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
WHY. NINETY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
I DON'T CARE EMILY GABEL LUDDY
PATH THERE COULD BE A BURBANK.
WE SPENDING LITTLE CALIFORNIA
AND THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY ASKING
RESPECTFULLY BY NO VOTE SB MANI.
SPLINE. ONE TWENTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING JUST MATTER WITH THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. ONE TO THIRTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
PHILADELPHIA CRANES ON BEHALF
OF SILICON VALLEY AND HOME
ACTION FUNDING SUPPORT. WINE.
ONE FORTY THREE. GOOD MORNING
MA'AM CHU ROTH ON THE OF THE C.
GOVERNMENT NO MATTER CAL STATE
AND ON BEHALF OF JAIL IN
SUPPORT. ONE TO THIRTY. GOOD
MORNING ANASTASIA CULTURE COULD
CALIFORNIANS VISORS ON BEHALF
OF SPENDING IN THE COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS IN THE POSITION
THANK YOU. LYING TO TWENTY
EIGHT. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND
IT'S HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION
INSTANCE STRONG OPPOSITION
BASED ON POLICY REASONS AS
EXPRESSED IN OUR LETTER THANK
YOU. MORNING ON THE ASSEMBLY
DOES ON BEHALF OF THE TRI
VALLEY CITIES AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. BLIND ONE EIGHT NINE.
NICOLE ORNEMANN ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF ONTARIO IN
OPPOSITION. LINE TO TWENTY. MY
NAME IS WE THE PEOPLE NOT THE
GOVERNMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. WITH THE ONE.
JENNIFER KENNEDY A RESIDENT OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE. THANK
YOU PINE FORTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS HOLLY
OSBORNE I'M A REGISTERED
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEER IN
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE SB NINE
THANK YOU. FINE TUNE. NINETEEN
PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT ONE TO
NINETEEN THE LINE IS NOW OPEN.
OKAY A GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MAILING STAFF AND ON BEHALF OF
SUNNYVALE UNITED NEIGHBORS
MEMBER OF UNITED NEIGHBORS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB NINE
THANK YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
RAYMOND STONE SPEAKING FOR US
ANGELES WESTWOOD BOULEVARD
SOUTH OF SANTA MONICA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB NINE AS
AMENDED. LINE. ONE EIGHTY ONE.
HI THIS IS MATT STOPPER I'M
CALLING ON THE ON BEHALF OF THE
RESIDENTS OF LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK BLIND
ONE SIXTY SEVEN.HE'S GONE NOW
THE MORNING MANAGER MEMBERS
IT'S ALL BUT START WITH RUNNING
PUBLIC POLICY GROUP
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
CARLSBAD DELMON CORONA AND BUMP
IT CITY APARTMENTS AMENDED.
ALTHOUGH THE CITY AT THE
THOUGHT IN. OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY SIX.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS NINA LABEL ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF THOUSAND OAKS AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
LYING TO TWENTY SIX. TRACY
THROWER CONYERS UNITED
NEIGHBORS OF WEST LOS ANGELES
NO AS AMENDED. ONE TWO ELEVEN.
MY TO A LEVEL YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS ALEXANDER
GUSEV REPRESENTING THE L. THREE
DON'T COMMITTEE COUNSEL IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB NINE
THANK YOU. BLIND. ONE TWENTY
FOUR. HELLO THIS IS LIBERTY
STRONG OPPOSITION SB. NINE ONE
TO TWENTY FOUR. HI THIS IS AN
GREENSPON A BOARD MEMBER OF
NOMARCH THOUGHT ORGANIZATION OF
OVER FOUR THOUSAND MIXED UNITS
IN HOMES IN SANTA MONICA AND DO
NOTHING TO COURT SB NINE. FIND.
SIXTY THREE. INJURY ANSWERING
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS IN OPPOSITION TO
SB NINE. LINE. SIXTY SEVEN. HI
MY NAME IS SARAH MERITS NOT BY
THE I'M A CONSTITUENT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JESSE GABRIEL I
AGREE WITH THE CLIMATE ACTION
GROUP- CAL FIFTY THANK YOU. BYE
BYE. TWO THIRTY EIGHT. TWO
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PAUL
GUNS ALL THIS ON BEHALF OF
TWENTY THREE CITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. LINE. TO TWENTY
FIVE. HI JEANNIE WAS NASTY
FEHLEN I'M COVER CITY NEIGHBORS
UNITED IN OPPOSITION I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING FIFTY FOUR
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THANK YOUR
COLLEGE THANK YOU LINE TO FORTY
EIGHT. DORAN'S LEGAL ADVISERS
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB NINE THANK YOU. BY. TWO
FORTY FOUR. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JASON RYAN THE LEADER
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN OPPOSITION
TO SB NINE. LINE TWO OH NINE.
MARK REGALADO BASSES SANTA
MONICA CROSSED A RESIDENTS AN
AFFILIATE OF UNITED NEIGHBORS
CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
SB NINE AS AMENDED THANK YOU I
WANT TO FORTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO EUROPE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF SAN MARCOS
GLENDALE BURBANK MARIN COUNTY
COUNCIL OF MAYORS AND
COUNCILMEMBERS AND THE TOWN OF
TRUCKEE ALL IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE. BY. ONE FIFTY TWO. YOUR
NUMBERS NOT ONLY ON THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THINK. ONE TWO FORTY
TWO. GOOD MORNING HEARING I'M A
HOMEOWNER IN ELMHURST
NEIGHBORHOOD SACRAMENTO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIND
TO THIRTEEN. MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH HENRY- REPRESENTING
ST LAFAYETTE LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
AND UNITED NEIGHBORS AND CALLIE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE. BY. TWO FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MODERATE TOP ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
ONE TO THIRTY THREE. MY NAME IS
DEBBIE HAWK WITH RESOLUTE ON
BEHALF OF HIDDEN HILLS AND
BUILD AFFORDABLE FACTOR
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION UNLESS
AMENDED FOR AFFORDABILITY THANK
YOU LINE TO THIRTY SEVEN. KCLU
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
LAFAYETTE CUPERTINO IN
OPPOSITION. BLIND FIFTY NINE
ALL. SH HELLO THE VICE MAYOR
CHILI PEPPER ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF PLEASANTON IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE. BY. TWO
THIRTY. THIS IS RECALL WITH
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA- IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. LINE TWO SIXTY TWO.
THE PARENTS KNOW ABOUT THE I-
MERGING NO VOTE ON AT. FIFTY
NINE. LINE. TWO SIXTY FOUR.
PARDON ME PARDON ME. FINAL CALL
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO. FIND ONE
TWENTY FIVE. MYERS C. DEMO FROM
THE SOUTH BAY BUT SENATE
DISTRICT STATE STREET THIS.
LINE. TWO FIFTY SEVEN. ROBIN IS
THE ARIENS FROM AARP CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF XP NINE.
ONE MOMENT MADAM CHAIR. OKAY
LINE. TO FOURTEEN. THANK TO
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HOLLY PICKEREL CALLING SAN
DIEGO IN REPRESENTING OUR
ISLAND SOUTH BAY AREA IN
OPPOSITION. LINE ONE TWENTY
FIVE. MY CDMO IN THE POSTSEASON
A STRONG OPPOSITION. LONG LINE
IN SIXTY. MY LINE IT TO SIXTY
AND I WANT TO URGE- NO VOTE ON
SB NINE THANK YOU. LINE. TWO
FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
JACQUELINE HOUSING IS A HUMAN
RIGHT HM STRONG OPPOSITION. ONE
TO FIFTEEN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THAT MAKES
NEARING WE- R. I'M SORRY-
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT DID THAT
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
UNDERSTANDABLE SITUATION I
DON'T KNOW HIM AT ALL. LINE
BLIND. TO SIXTY SEVEN. GROWING
CALLING ON BEHALF OF NIGHT OR
ELECTRIC NORTH AMERICA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LINE. TWO FORTY SEVEN- JACQUI
ACKLAND WEST TOWARDS HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY OPPOSED.
LINE TWO SIXTY THREE. YES THIS
IS DEBBIE PRICE OF LOS ALTOS
HILLS CALIFORNIA TOWN OF LOS
ALTOS HILLS STRONGLY OPPOSED.
LINE TWO SIXTY THREE PARDON ME
JUST A MOMENT. BUT. NINE TO
FORTY NINE. YES MY NAME IS
KERRY CAKE MAKING REPRESENTING
WESTWOOD HILLS PROPERTY OWNERS
ASSOCIATION AT SIX HUNDRED
FAMILIES IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
NINE TO SIXTY FIVE. AMERICA.
MISSION BEACH STRONG OPPOSITION.
I'M SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
OPERATE OUT THROUGH THOSE
NICELY- IN THE CHAMBER IS
ANYBODY HERE WANNA SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE. SEE NOBODY WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OTHER IS
SOMEBODY ALL RIGHT. THE SHIP.
HOLD ON FINANCE. FROM A WIRE
CALIFORNIA WERE VERY OF STRONG
OPPOSED TO SB NINE THANK YOU
ANYBODY ELSE. IF THERE'S
ANYTHING ELSE WE SHOULD WALK
DOWN TOWARDS THE MICROPHONE.
THANK THE MORNING CARE GONZALEZ
MEMBERS MARK GRAHAM ON BEHALF
OF KEEP CELL AND THE WAY THEY
WERE SO STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE-
THANK YOU. SEE NOBODY ELSE
COMING TO MICROPHONE WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOW
MAILING. FINANCE HAS THE
OPPOSITE. ANNUAL COST FIFTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ONGOING. FINANCES NOT
ANTICIPATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE TO RESULT FROM THE
STUFF. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SEE
NO QUESTIONS FROM. THE MEMBERS
WILL TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND JUST TO SAY THAT PERMIT
FEES- IS WELLS IMPACT FEES
STILL APPLY SO THERE WOULD NOT
BE THE IMPACT IN REGARDS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
DON'T THINK EVEN CHECK THANK
YOU THAT GETS ON A ROLL CALL
WITH MISTER BRIAN MISTER CHOW
AND MR VOEPEL NOT VOTING AND
MISTER BIGELOW VOTING NO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR STERN I THINK
YOU WERE NEXT. WELL MISTER
BECKER. I MISSED YOU. MISTER
BECKER SB FIVE OH THREE AND I
THINK YOUR PRESENT TíNH FOR
MISS GONZALEZ AS WELL CORRECT
YES WE'LL START WITH YOUR BILL
SB FIVE A THREE TO JOYS I DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO AND- A
SECOND. BITE MISTER BRIAN THANK
YOU. EXCELLENT THANK YU GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS THIS IS BILLS
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY INCREASING
COMMUNICATION WITH VOTERS
BETTER DATA AND CODIFYING WHAT
WE KNOW WORKS FROM NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY. AS RELATES TO
FISCAL IMPACT THE SUGGESTED
ESTIMATES A FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
COST. IN FOR OUR COUNTY
ELECTION OFFICIALS AND- THE
CLERKS ESTIMATED COST OF
SENDING POSTAGE PAID LETTERS
WITH POST PAID RETURN ENVELOPES
PART OF THE BILL WITH
500-007-5000 PER ELECTION. THAT
INCLUDES POSTAGE TO MAIL RETURN
THE LETTERS AND LABOR TO LABOR
TO ASSEMBLE AND RECEIVE
LETTERS. ALTERNATIVELY THIS
GIVES CONFIDENCE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS DEVELOP THOSE
AREN'T THAT COUNTED AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SEEN NO
WITNESSES WERE GOING TO GO TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR ANYBODY WHO
WANTS ROGER THEIR SUPPORT. OR
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE A THREE.
AND WE APOLOGIZE FOR ANYONE WHO
MAY WISH TO SPEAK IN REGARDS TO
THE PREVIOUS BILL WE ASK YOU.
TO REMOVE YOURSELF FROM THE
QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE NINE
ERO. IF YOU ARE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OR OPPOSITION TO
THE CURRENT BILL PLEASE PRESS
ONE NINE ZERO. I'M GONNA GO TO
LINE. ONE SIXTY THREE- O'CONNOR
IN MADERA COUNTY IN OPPOSITION
AND ALSO VERY CONFUSED BY THE
ORDER OF THE AGENDA NOT CALLING
WHAT'S LISTED. BY. TWO TWENTY.
ANDREA HAD SIR- I ECHO WHAT SHE
SAID YOU'RE NOT FOLLOWING THE
AGENDA THIS IS CONFUSING TO
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU OF MINE
TOO TWENTY ONE. JENNIFER
KENNEDY RESIDENTS L. A. COUNTY
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. LINE TWO
SIXTY ONE. TRICIA CRANE SANTA
MONICA SANTA MONICA CITY
COUNCIL AND LOS ANGELES CITY
COUNCIL HAVE OPPOSED SB. NINE
WE ARE ONLY GOING TO GO ON SB
FIVE OH THREE HE ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THEN GO
TO LINE. ONE TWENTY FOUR. YES
IT IS LIBERTY AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE CURRENT BILL.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU I DO WANT TO DRESS- IF
THERE'S ANYBODY AND THE- IN THE
CHAMBERS THAT WANTS TO SPEAK
PLEASE GOT A MICROPHONE BUT I
DO WANT TO ADDRESS THE FACT
THAT WE GO. OUT OF AGENDA ORDER
IN THIS COMMITTEE WE DO WE GO
ACCORDING TO WHAT AUTHORS HERE
AND WHEN THEY ARE HERE WE HAVE
A MORE BILLS THAN ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE I THINK OVER A
HUNDRED SEVENTY TODAY AND SO
THAT'S HOW WE GET OUR BUSINESS
DONE. I'M SORRY- PAST. SO YOU
YOU SHOULD FOLLOW ALONG WITH
THE BILL THAT WE'RE ON- WITH
THAT. I SEE NOBODY IN THE- IN.
IN- THE CHAMBER- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. A NEW ELECTION RELATED
TO STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE
THIS BILL WILL RESULT IN ONE
TIME COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND FOR THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO PROMULGATE REGULATIONS WHICH
FINANCE BELIEVES IS LIKELY
ABSORB ALL. THE STATE THIS BILL
MAY CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE BECAUSE IT REQUIRES AN
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL TO APPLY
CERTAIN PRESUMPTIONS SUBSEQUENT
TO THE INITIAL CMPARISON OF A
VOTER SIGNATURE TO DETERMINE
THAT A VOTER SIGNATURES VALID
AND TO IDENTIFY AND PROVIDE
DATA. ON THE NUMBER OF BALLOTS
REJECTED CATEGORIZED ACCORDING
TO THE REASON FOR THE REJECTION
AS SPECIFIED FOR EVERY ELECTION
THE MAGNITUDE OF THIS MANDATE
EXPOSURE IS UNKNOWN BUT COULD
BE SIGNIFICANT. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YEP YES FOR
AND I'VE GOT A FRONT ROW ALL
RIGHT- IT'S A RECORD THAT GETS
OUT OF THE ROLL CALL THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO MAKE AND SALAS IT'S SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT OF A MOTION BY
MISS CARILLO- A SECOND BY
MISTER BRIAN YOU MAY PROCEED.
EXCELLENT THAT PRESENTING THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT AND A HALF CENTER
CONSOLIDATES THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE IN CLOSING DIGITAL
DIVIDE BY PROVIDING CLARITY TO
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ON BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT
SPECIFICALLY MICRO TRENCHING-
THIS DOES NOT HAVE ANY STATE
COSTS AND RECEIVE NO NOVO
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. THANK YOU AYE STRICTLY
AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE ON S. B.
THREE SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU
WILL GO TO PHONE LINES ANYONE
THAT WANTS REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT. FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT OF THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
ONE TWENTY THREE. GOOD MORNING
JUST AN IRAQI SPOKE ABOUT
LEADERSHIP GROUP IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU BYE ONE
THIRTY ONE. MAKES A LOT OF ON
BEHALF OF CROWN CASTLE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I TO CLEAR DETAILED. YES
GOOD MORNING- MY NAME IS DR
CHERYL SHARE ITEMS
REPRESENTING- FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS OF THE FREEDOM WRITING
IN MARIN COUNTY AND I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSING. THANK YOU.
THERE IS NO ONE OUT OF PARDON
ME WE DO HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
PERSON BY ONE TWENTY FIVE. YES
MY NAME IS MARCY EMR I'M
CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY. THANK YOU
THREE SEVEN. THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK GREAT ARE THE PEOPLE IN
THE AUDIENCE WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
MORNING SECONDS ALL OF MEMBERS
MARKRAM. RIGHT THE
ORGANIZATION'S NAME AND IT IS
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
KNOW THAT TUNNEL BORING AS THE
MAGNIFICENT WAY OF INSTALLING
WAIT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE THREE
WORDS OR LESS WE'RE NOT GONNA
PLAY THIS GAME SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR OPPOSITION WILL MOVE ON.
MY NAME IS PAUL MCGAVIN ON JUST
AS HUGE COST HAPPEN FROM MICRO
TRENCHING THANK YOUNG UP ALL
THIS THANK YOU. KIM ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YOU HAVE TO FILE. YES BECAUSE
NO STATE LEVEL FISCAL IMPACT
AND ANTICIPATE NO REIMBURSABLE
STATEMENT IT COSTS ON LOCAL
AGENCIES ANY COSTS INCURRED BY
LOCAL AGENCIES CAN BE COVERED
BY THE FEW AUTHORITY OVER
PROVIDES TO THOSE AGENCIES.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DISCUSSION
BY THE COMMITTEE- I'LL TAKE
THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES MR BACK ON
BEHALF OF MY SCHOOL AND SALAS-
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU. MR STERN. SB. THREE
SEVENTY. THAT'S CORRECT MILLION
ENJOY A DEEP RECOMMENDATION
WOULD AS MOTION BY MISTER AND A
SECOND BY BRIAN YOU MAY PURSUE.
THANK YOU WILL BE- POST BY THE
OF LOS ANGELES AND THE CAL
PUBLIC TO THIS. AND REALLY
WE'RE TRYING TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE WERE COMP INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL- RECEIVE TIME FOR
THEIR CREDIT SERVE NOT JUST
WHEN THEY'RE IN A COUNTY JAIL
BUT ALSO WHEN THEY'RE IN A
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
FACILITY WE THINK THIS WILL
ACTUALLY SAVE MONEY. FROM A
FISCAL PERSPECTIVE IT ALSO BE A
MUCH MORE JUST OUTCOME I'VE
I'VE TAKEN AMENDMENTS IN THIS
COMMITTEE TO RESPOND TO SOME
AMBIGUITIES REYES ABOUT THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL IN ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY SO I APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
I APPRECIATE THAT- WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES IS THERE
ANYBODY WANTS REGISTER SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE
SEVENTEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. TO THREE SEVENTEEN.
THERE IS CALLED ME JUST A
MOMENT. AND AGAIN WE INVITE
PEOPLE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE
ONE WITH A LINE THAT SIGNAL
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT. MY CAT SCAN. JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT THANK. WHEN I GO
TO LINE TWO SEVENTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING DONNA FACT THAT ****
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS PROUD CO SPONSOR AT
THREE SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. EACH
LINE SEVENTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING AFFECT MY REGULAR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION PROG CODE
BONTA SB THREE SEVENTEEN IN
SUPPORT. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU I'M WILL GO AHEAD AND
BRING IT INTO THE COMMITTEE I
SEE NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GIVE A
FILE. A MILLION. PARIS WE HAVE
LOST THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I BUT THAT'S OKAY. AM I HERE
YES I CAN HEAR YOU OKAY SORRY
ABOUT THAT- FINANCE HAS NO
POSITION ON THIS BILL THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ESTIMATES THE
COSTS RELATED TO THIS BILL ARE
MINOR AND THAT SORT OF- WITHIN
EXISTING RESOURCES. THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
ESTIMATES NO COST TO IMPLEMENT
THIS BILL THIS BILL MAY RESULT
IN COST SAVINGS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE REDUCTION IN. AVERAGE DAILY
PRISON JACK COPULATIONS. AND
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVED A COULD
NOT CONDUCT CREDITS REDUCING
THEIR SENTENCE OR HAVING THEIR
CHARGES DISMISSED ENTIRELY FOR
COMPLETION OF A DIVERSION
PROGRAM. AT THIS TIME THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
AND FINANCE ARE UNABLE TO
ESTIMATE THE MAGNITUDE OF SUCH
SAVINGS. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I SEE NO COMMENTS I
TAKE THAT IS YOUR CLOTHES MR
STERN. THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
PRESENT FOR MR WHY CASKEY AS
WELL SB FIVE THIRTY ONE ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WE ARE
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND
BY MISTER BRIAN YOU MAY
PROCEED. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- BILL REQUIRES PRIVATE
DEBT COLLECTORS TO PROVIDE THE
DEBTOR WITH CERTAIN INFORMATION
ABOUT THE DEBTS BEING COLLECTED
LIKE THE BALANCE OF THE DEAD
REASON FOR ANY INTEREST AND
FEES ON A COPY OF THE CONTRACT-
THE COST OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I DO I'M SORRY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION- AS
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES
ARE MINOR IN OBSERVABLE AND
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES IS ANYBODY
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB.
FIVE THIRTY ONE. THANKS
COMMITTEE BUILT ON NEXT WEEK.%
ARE THERE ANY- ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE FOR SB FIVE THIRTY ONE.
PARDON ME AGAIN FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR FIVE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO. IT'S. ONE NINE ZERO.
ONE MOMENT YEAH. GONNA GO TO
LINE. TWO NINETY FOUR. OKAY
YOUR LINE IS. RIGHT TO NINETY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU NINETY FOUR PLAYS. YES YOUR
LINE I DON'T KNOW THE- I DON'T
KNOW. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU AND I THINK WE HAVE
SOME PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR OR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AS WELL.
THIS IS TO FIVE THIRTY ONE BORN
INTO ORGANS ALL OF THE MEMBERS
PRESERVE LOCAL ZONING AUTHORITY
OVER THE PLACEMENT OF CELL
ANTENNAS I AM OPPOSED. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS- I'M A
CALIFORNIA'S ONE JUST ADD OUR
RIGHTS VERY ALL RIGHT YOU CAN
NOT LIMITING ORGANIZATION TO
THREE THANK YOU I ACTUALLY CAN
LIMIT PUBLIC COMMENT TO NOTHING
SO THANK YOU YOU SHUT OFF THE
MICROPHONE PLEASE. I WANT TO BE
REALLY CLEAR PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS LEGISLATIVE HEARING IS
SOMETHING WE HAVE AGREED TO ADD
IT IS NOT A RIGHT SO IF YOU
CANNOT ABIDE BY THE RULES THIS
COMMITTEE WE WILL SHUT YOU DOWN
AND HAVE YOU REMOVED THAT IS
OUR RULES. WE ARE DOING YOU AND
HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT YOUR POSITION AND THAT
IS IT WE ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE
THIS BE A CIRCUS WITH THAT. I
WILL GO I WILL GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FINANCE
HAS NO POSITION ON MY MANTLE
ACOSTA OF FINANCIAL PROTECTION
AND INNOVATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WANT TO BE REALLY
CLEAR THAT I HAVE A THREE
STRIKES AND YOU'RE OUT RULE SO
IT ONE MORE OUTBURST OR NOT
ABIDING BY THE RULES AND
GENTLEMEN I WILL ASK THE
SERGEANTS TO. ESCORT YOU OUT.
ANYTHING FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SEEN NONE WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
ASK FOR CLOTHES THANK YOU MR
STERN ON BEHALF OF MR WHITE
HOUSE CAME BACK IT'S OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THAT MR LIBERTY NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER NEWMAN. YOU
HAVE SB THREE SIXTY TWO- I'M-
NOT. GOT A MIXER THERE AS IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
I HAVE A MOTION BY MS CARILLO
IN A SECOND BY DAVE MISTER
BRIAN. ALL RIGHT MISTER NEWMAN
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MANAGER MEMBERS SB
THREE SIXTY TWO WOULD PROHIBIT
THE ASSIGNMENT ENFORCEMENT OF
QUOTAS OR PERFORMANCE BASED
METRICS THAT INTERFERE WITH THE
ABILITY OF PHARMACISTS TO
RENDER THE HIGHEST STANDARDS OF
CARE. LIKE SCHILLING PHARMACIST
FROM HAVING TO SATISFY QUOTAS
WHICH COMPETE WITH TEIR
OBLIGATIONS TO THEIR PATIENTS
SB THREE SIXTY TWO WILL ENSURE
THAT THEY WILL BE FULLY ABLE TO
HONOR THEIR OWES TO MAKE
MEDICAL DECISIONS BASED ON
PATIENT NEEDS RATHER THAN
CORPORATE GOALS WITH THE RECENT
REMOVAL OF OPPOSITION BY THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. THERE IS CURRENTLY
NO ACTIVE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL- WITH ME BY PHONE IF THEIR
QUESTIONS ARE JESSE G. GROUP
WITH THE U. S. C. W. WESTERN
STATE COUNCIL INITIAL RIVAS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
WE'RE GONNA GO THE WITNESSES
AND ASK ONLY ON THE FISCAL LESS
THAN TWO MINUTES THANK YOU. HI
MISS CHARLIE THAT'S WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOUNG. THANK
YOU. JAVY ARE YOU THERE. YES
I'M HERE JACQUI VERY WELL
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR WITH THE
U. F. C. W. WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND GO TO
THE PHONE LINES ANYONE THAT
WANTS TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE
SIXTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. TWENTY THREE OH
THREE. FINE THREE OH THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. WHEN I GO TO
LINE NINETY NINE. HELLO THIS IS
LIBERTY STRONG OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL. HAPPENS AGAIN FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS WHAT
NINE ZERO. THERE IS NO NEW
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU I'M WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SAY YOUR NAME
EIGHT AT ACTUAL ORGANIZATION
THAT IS SHORT AND- YOUR
POSITION YOU ARE WELCOME TO DO
SO. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MARKRAM MINIMIZE
ELECTROMAGNETIC RADIATION ARE.
OPPOSED THANK YOUNG. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR GONZALEZ AND
MEMBERS OPPOSE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS TIERNEY. THANK
YOU. WHAT CAN WE GO AHEAD TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FINANCE
HAS NOT HELD. THE WATER PARKS
WILL INCUR COSTS. OF NINETY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS PHARMACY BOARD
CONTINGENT FUND FOUR ONE HALF-INSPECTOR POSITION FINANCE
BELIEVES THE ADDITIONAL COSTS
FROM THE. BILL LIKELY WILL NOT
BE ABSORBED BECAUSE THE BILL
HAS REGARD. AS REQUIRED BUDGET
ARE GOING TO BUY A POSITION
WITHIN THE LAST THREE FISCAL
YEARS FOR INCREASING
ENFORCEMENT COSTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT MR NUMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I'LL
TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES.
THANK YOU. SEEN NO QUESTIONS-
BACK IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU THE MANAGER. WHERE UP
TO MY SENATOR MISTER WEST SO.
YOU HAVE TO BUILD A SITE WILL
START WITH SB SEVEN TWELVE IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
OF EMOTION BY MISS CARILLO. AND
A SECOND FIVE MINUTES RIVAS.
OKAY. THANK YOU SEE MYSELF
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS BILL WILL RECTIFY NEARS
THE YEARS OF THE DOOR MY DAY
TODAY I DON'T BLAME OUR- YAQOOB
THERE ARE NONE ON ALL BILL.
WELL I THE SUPPORT BUT WE DON'T
WANT EVERYBODY HERE. WHAT'S
GOING ON OKAY TURN. SERVICE
LIKE THAT TODAY JUST ONE AND-
MISTER WEST SO OKAY I'LL I'LL
BEFORE THANK YOU APPRECIATED
THAT THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO PRESENT SB SEVEN TWELVE THIS
WILL RECTIFY YEARS OF
LONGSTANDING DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT HAVE DEPRIVE NATIVE
AMERICANS FROM A FAIR PROCESS
IN THEIR ATTEMPTS TO ACQUIRED
CESSPOOL ANNE'S. NATIVE
AMERICANS HAVE SUFFERED FROM
DECADES OF VIOLENCE
MISTREATMENT EXPLOITATION
ATTEMPTED DESTRUCTION OF TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES AND DISPOSITION. OF
ASSETS ANCESTRAL LANDS THIS
BILL FURTHER REQUIRES A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHO OPPOSES AN
APPLICATION TO INCLUDE
INFORMATION PROVIDED BY THE
TRIBE ON THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS
THAT THE TRIBE IS MADE TO THE
COUNTY THIS IS. A REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE TRIBES
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE SIGNIFICANT
THEY ARE OFTEN A NEGLECTED AND
UNDER NORD SO- TRIBES ARE
SUPPORT LOCAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS
THEY MAKE INFRASTRUCTURE
ENHANCEMENTS THEY IMPROVE
HOUSING AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PREVENTS. AMONG MANY OTHER
THINGS CREATING JOBS WE MUST
TAKE THESE BENEFITS INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN MAKE MAKING
A DECISION ON WHETHER TO
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE FEET FEET
A TRUST ACQUISITION SO. I ASK
OF THAT- WE- SUPPORTS BILL
TODAY SUPPORT OUR TRIBES TO
HAVE A FAIR PROCESS AND
CONSIDERING WHETHER TO ACQUIRE
ADJUSTABLE LANDS OR NOT. AS I
HAVE A WITNESS TODAY MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
CHAIRMAN BO MAZZETTI WITH THE
RINCON BAND OF LUSITANIA
INDIANS- IF HE'S AVAILABLE TO
SPEAK OF FOR. THE OF THE
CHAIRMAN WOULD ALLOW THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN'S ATTY IF YOU'RE THERE.
CAN YOU GIVE YOUR TWO MINUTES.
HELLO THERE MY AUNT. HI NUMBER
YEP. OKAY OKAY WELL HOW ABOUT
OBSCURE ENOUGH MEMBERS OF W.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HI MY
NAME IS BOTH OF THAT EIGHT OF
THE TERM OF THE RING COMBAT THE
LOWEST PAID MILLIONS OF WE ARE
THE SPONSORS OF THE EVENT WELL
ADDITIONALLY THE CALIFORNIA
TRIBAL CURTAIN FOR THE FROM THE
PORT CLUB WELL. UNLIKE THE BAG
YOU. BUT FOR THE VERY WORD THAT
USE THAT THEY HAVE ABOUT PEOPLE
WORK THROUGH THE BILL. WE WILL
LOOK AT THE- AS WELL AS- THE IN
COMMITTEE NOT WHAT THE PRODUCT
WILL BE. I'D LIKE MADE. THE
ONLY FISCALLY MP WOULD BE. ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WOULD BE
SENDING A CERTIFIED LETTER TO A
TRIED. ACCORDING TO THE UNITED
STATES POSTAL SERVICE WEBSITE A
CERTIFIED LETTER MCCARTY OKAY
THE ONLY THREE DOLLARS AND
FIFTY CENTS. VERY MINIMAL. ARE
ONLY THREE DOLLARS AND FIFTY
FILL. SB SEVEN TWELVE. RECTIFY
THAT THEIR FAULT THAT THE FEARS
OF LONGSTANDING DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES OR POLICIES THAT HAVE
KEPT. CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RECOGNIZED RIGHT A FAIR PROCESS.
IN ORDER TO TAP. RIGHT BY
BETHEL HAVE. BEEN THROUGH A LOT.
I STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN WILL NOW GO TO THE
GENERAL PHONE LINES PEOPLE WHO
WENT TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN TO
WILD. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. GOING TO GO TO LINE. ONE
SIXTY THREE THIRTY. MY NAME IS
TO O'CONNOR MADERA COUNTY I
OPPOSE AND I ALSO REITERATE
THIS IMPOSSIBLE TO FOLLOW AND
COLOR COMMENTED OBVIOUSLY NO
BATTERY SORRY I'M HIGH I WANNA
REMIND ANYONE IF YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO SHARE
YOUR POSITION YOU ARE WELCOME
TO SUBMIT A LETTER OR AN EMAIL
TO THE COMMITTEE- IN ORDER TO
ENSURE WE KNOW YOUR FULL
POSITION ON EVERY BALLOT. WITH
THAT ANYONE WHO WANTS
REGISTERED THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO SB. SEVEN TWELVE.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU WILL GO AHEAD AND GO TO THE
AUDIENCE. THANK A CHART OF
THOSE MEMBERS MONIES PALMA
GAVIN WHERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND WE- DO NOT RECOGNIZE
OUR VOICES THANK YOUNG WELSH BY
THE CHAIR THANK YOU. I'M I'M
GONNA ASK NOW THAT YOU EXIT THE
ROOM BECAUSE THAT IS I DON'T
KNOW THE FIFTH TIME I THINK
I'VE ASKED YOU TO STICK TO THE
RULES. SO SERGEANTS IF YOU CAN
PLEASE HAVE A MIX OF THE WERE
THE- BUILDING I'M SERIOUS WHEN
I SAY WE'RE GOING TO BUY BY
RULES IN THIS. YOU SAY YOUR
NAME AT YOUR OGANIZATION AND
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THAT IS WHAT
YOU DO IN THIS COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE COMMENTARIES SIR GO
AHEAD. PLEASE SIR YOU'RE AT THE
MICROPHONE SORRY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SPEAK. BOB GRAHAM DOES DO
THE MEMBERS READ POSITION IRATE
THANK YOU. I YOU CAN BOTH LEAVE
NOW THIS THIS IS ENOUGH. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HI THERE.
THIS BILL AND WE DO NOT
ANTICIPATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE TO RESULT FROM THIS
BILL AS WELL. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I SEE NO COMMENT- I
TEN TAKE OUT OF YOUR CLOTHES
SENATOR WAS SO UNLESS YOU WANT
TO ADD SOMETHING I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT GETS OUT
WITHIN A ROLL CALL WITH MISS
DOLLY NOT VOTING WILL GO TO
YOUR SECOND BILL NOW SB SEVEN
THIRTY FORD ENJOYS  DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OF A MOTION BY
MISS RIVAS HAVE A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO. YES THANK YOU ON
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR THIS BILL
WOULD- ALLOW. THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REAP- FOR CITIES TO
RENEGOTIATE. AMOUNTS OF THAT-
THAT THEY HAVE. ACCRUED WITH
COUNTIES WITH RESPECT TO
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES THAT
JUST ALLOWS THE CONVERSATION TO
HAPPEN. ALLOWS FOR THE
RENEGOTIATION TO HAPPEN IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE IT AS A
MANDATE. IT'S A SIMPLE BILL
THAT RULES ALLOW. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO RESTRUCTURE THE
REPAYMENT OF DEBT. IT DOESN'T-
FORGIVE THE DEBT IT JUST ALLOWS
HIM TO RENEGOTIATE ASSET- YOU
SUPPORT. SB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR
PRECIADO VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
I'M WITH THAT WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES ANYBODY WANTS
REGISTER THERE'S NO- WITNESSES
BUT IF ANYONE WANTS TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
SB. SEVEN THIRTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM GERMAN A
GERMAN- MY NAME IS ARNOLD
ALBERS GLASSMAN THE CITY
ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF P.
CARTER AND I NEED TO PARK. A CO
SPONSORS OR SUPPORTERS OF THIS
BILL- AS THE ANGELS INDICATED
THE THANK YOU WE DO SUPPORT
THIS. THANK YOU THANK YOU. M.
ME- THAT THAT PERSON MAY HAVE
CALLED THEM AS A WAY. OF MADAM
CHAIR I HAVE NO WAY THAT IS
CORRECT I HAVE NO WITNESS
LISTED FOR THIS BILL SO WILL
TAKE HIS SUPPORT AND REGISTER
IT. AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO OTHER
SUPPORT OPPOSITION. FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WHEN I GO. TO TWO
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
TWO NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES THIS IS LIBERTY NEAR-
I AM SHOWING OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR PANORAMA AS
WELL THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON IS SINGLE BUT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK ONE MOMENT.
GO TO BIND. THREE FIFTEEN. AND
THREE FIFTEEN NO ONE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ROSEMARY
PRITCHARD I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF ACTORS EQUITY AND I STRONGLY
URGE SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT OH
FIVE. THANK YOU KNOW THAT IS
NOT THE BILL WE'RE ON- WE ARE
ON WEST THOSE AS SENATOR WITH
HIS BILL SEVEN THIRTY FOUR
ANYBODY WANT TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THAT
BILL. I'M SURE THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU LOOK AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOW.
FINANCES NEUTRAL UP. WE HAD A
BIG. IMPACT SHOULD CARE TO
FOURTEEN SCHOOLS RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL RESIDUAL PROPERTY
TAX REVENUES. BECAUSE TEST ONE
OF PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT IS
NOT OPERATIVE AND IS XPECTED
TO BE OPERATIVE FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE. WHAT LED
YOU TO CHOOSE THE MOVE OUT OF
TEST ONE THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND IMPACT IS
UNKNOWN BUT LARGELY DEPENDENT
ON THE EXTENT TO WHICH PASSED
THROUGH AGREEMENTS ARE
MODIFIED. A RENEGOTIATED PASSED
THROUGH AGREEMENT WILL NOT
RESULT IN A SUCCESSOR AGENCY
RECEIVING ANY BENEFIT FISCAL OR
OTHERWISE. IF PASSED THROUGH
AGREEMENTS WHICH ARE PAID WITH
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE I
RENEGOTIATED TO LOWER INTEREST
RATES OR THE DEBT IS FORGIVEN.
THE RECIPIENT AFFECTED TAXING
AGED ENTITY WILL RECEIVE LOWER
PASS THROUGH PAYMENTS HOWEVER
AFFECTED TAXING ENTITIES
INCLUDING KATE OF FOURTEEN
SCHOOLS MAY ALSO RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL RESIDUAL PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE AFTER ALL OF THE
SUCCESSOR AGENCIES PAYMENTS ARE
MADE IN A CERTAIN PERIOD.
FINANCE DOES NOT ANTICIPATE
THIS BILL CREATES A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE BECAUSE
ANY COSTS INCURRED BY LOCAL
AGENCIES WILL BE DUE TO THEIR
DISCRETIONARY DECISION. TO
EMPLOY THE BILL'S PROVISIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE'LL TAKE
THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES SENATOR
WEST SO WITH THAT IT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL I APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE. THANK YOU AND I
JUST WANNA SAY YOU'RE DOING A
GREAT JOB YOU HAVE A DIFFICULT
JOB. THANK YOU ALL THESE COLORS
ARE IT HEARING TO MY DOCTOR'S
ORDERS IT TO AVOID STRESS
CLEARLY- MRS GAYNOR SB EIGHT.
ENJOYS THE HOUSE RECOMMENDATION
I HAVE A MOTION BY MISS CARILLO
AS SECOND BY MISTER BRIAN YOU
MAY PROCEED THANKS SO MUCH SB
EIGHT JUST EXTENDS THE SUNSET
ON A VERY SUCCESSFUL BILL SB
THREE THIRTY THAT ALLOWS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO. PROCESS THE
PERMITS FASTER OF HOUSING THAT
MEETS LOCAL RULES SO THIS DOES
NOT CHANGED OWNING IT IS PURELY
HELPING MOVE A LITTLE FASTER
THAT HOUSING WHICH ALREADY
MEETS LOCAL RULES WITHOUT I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. SKINNER OF I JUST
ANNOUNCED THIS SENATOR YOU
CANNOT WAVE A BILL IT MISC IT'S
NOT DIRECTED ME SKINNER BUT
OTHER SENATORS YOU CAN YOU
CANNOT WAIT UTIL PRESENTATION
IF IT HAS SAID IF IT'S NOT
UNLESS IT'S GOING TO SUSPEND
SUPPORTERS ON CONSENT- WE CAN'T
TAKE YOUR BILL NEXT WEEK BUT
I'M GETTIN- INDICATIONS THAT
PEOPLE WANT TO WAY PRESENTATION
ON TO PASS BILLS I'D LOVE IF WE
COULD BUT- THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE
SO- FOR THOSE SENATORS WERE
HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR BILLS UP
NEXT WEEK IF THAT'S MORE
CONVENIENT. THANK YOU MISS
SKINNER WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONES NOW S. B. EIGHT- SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO. FINNA GO
TO LINE AT ONE THIRTY SIX. I
MEAN BROKEN SUNSET PARKSIDE
EDUCATION ACTION COMMITTEE OF
SAN FRANCISCO HELLO SURELY
CHISHOLM VILLAGE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. BY TWO
TWENTY. DO YOU THINK YOU'RE
ENTITLED TO KNOW SO YOU THANK
YOU I'M NOT ENTITLED TO
ANYTHING THREE THINGS. WHITE
CREATING A LINE IS OPEN. TRADE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO MOVE ON
TO LINE. TO FIFTY SIX. THE
MORNING MANAGER MEMBERS UNTIL
BUT THERE WASN'T ANY PUBLIC
POLICY GROUP REPRESENTING THE
CITY OF KARLSTAD IN OPPOSITION
SB EIGHT. THANK LINE. TO NINETY
NINE. HELLO THIS IS LIBERTY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT THANK
YOU AND HOPING AROUND LIKE.
LINE. SIXTY THREE. BY FIFTY
THREE A ONE IS OPEN. THE
MINIMUM BONTA LINEMEN THE.
SEVEN ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. I'M GONNA MOVE ON
TO LINE SEVENTY FOUR. IT'S GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WILLIAM MICHAEL BURKE
ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA AGAIN BEING BIRD
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION
FEDERAL PROPERTY COMPANY
ABANDONED HOUSING LOS ANGELES
AREA COUNCIL AND FACEBOOK THANK
YOU. WHY NINETY TWO. I'M SURE
THIS IS BOB NAILED HER FEELS
DEAD AND COMPANY- IN SUPPORTING
SB EIGHT. WHY. NINETY FOUR.
PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT. MY
NINETY FOUR YEAR LINES NOW OPEN.
THANKS HERE GOOD MORNING EMILY
GABEL LUDDY PASSED THEIR
BURBANK ABUSING LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA E. SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY IN STRONG OPPOSITION AT
THE END THANK YOU. LINE. TO
TWENTY ONE. SRI JENNIFER
KENNEDY RESIDENTS OF L. A.
COUNTY IN OPPOSITION. TRYING TO
THIRTY SIX. I MEAN I'M LEYVA ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF THOUSAND
OAKS AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU LINE. THREE OH ONE.
ONE THREE OH ONE THE LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FALCONS ALL THE SUMMING UP THE
CITY'S CAMERI- AND TORRANCE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE AT
THIS TIME PRESS ONE NINE ZERO.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE. THREE
TWENTY THREE. PARDON ME JUST A
MOMENT IN A GO TO LINE. THREE
TWENTY THREE. AGAIN I APOLOGIZE
JUST A MOMENT. TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE OH ONE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
DIFFERENCE PARAMOUNT NOT THAT
HE CONSTITUENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACQUI CAPE CORAL I OPPOSE SB
EIGHT THANK YOU. LYING. TWO
FORTY SEVEN. ONE TWO FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. BY
AT THREE TWENTY ARMY CORPS
HEADLINE TWO FORTY SEVEN. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES OKAY JACQUI
ACKLAND WORKS TOWARDS
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION STRONGLY
OPPOSED. ONE THREE TWENTY TWO
YOU WANT TO PRESCRIBE RESIDENT
LONG BEACH STRONGLY OPPOSE.
LINE THREE TWENTY. MY NAME IS
JOE HART WHAT I'M NOT ONLY
ABOUT AT NINE YEAH THANK YOU
BYE THREE TWENTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON JUST PRIOR TO TALK
ABOUT LEADERSHIP GROUP IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT THANK YOU.
LINE ONE TWENTY FIVE. MARCY
JEREMIAH FROM THAT SOUTH DAY IN
THE SUN PUBLIC SB EIGHT. BY.
NINETEEN NINETY THREE. THEY'LL
HELP TAKE SANTA ANA IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT. THERE'S
NO ONE OUT TO SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE AT WHICH IS TO
ADDRESSES HERE IN THE CHAMBER
SEEING NO ONE RALLIED TO THE
CALL. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU
HAVE ANY- COMMENTS ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR BIGELOW.
MISSION ON THIS BILL DEPART.
IT'S MY LOCAL COSTS AND FINANCE
DOES NOT ANTICIPATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE TO RESULT
FROM THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY MEMBERS HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR
SAYING NO ONE MISTER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE S. ZERO VOTE.
SIMPLY THAT BILL GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. MISTER KALRA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR VOLUNTEERING
TO PRESENT FOR MR ALLEN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO START WITH HIM
THAT'S- YES- THANK YOU MR SB
SIX SIX FOUR- BY SENATOR ALAN
ASSEMBLY US FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT IN
DEPTH PUTS. WE WILL. YOU HAVE
NO WITNESSES BUT WILL OPEN- THE-
LINES UP FOR FOLKS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
OPERATOR. ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. IT
APPEARS THAT NO ONE A SIGNAL
BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE I KEEP
GOING TO CHAIR DID COME BACK
BUT I THINK MR GARCIA WOULD
LIKE TO OFFER THE MOTION. AND
TO GRANT WILL SECOND THE MOTION
AND I'LL TURN IT BACK OVER TO
YOU IF YOU WANT AND CHERRY
WE'RE GONNA GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GO TO THE
FLOOR. THERE'S NOBODY IN.
THERE'S NO MEMBERS WOULD YOU
ADDRESSES AND PRO OR CON ON
THIS BILL. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES OKAY THANK. NEEDS
AND ABSORB COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH IT THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SEE NOBODY HAS ANYTHING
TO SAY WE'LL GET THAT OUT ON A
ROLL CALL WITH MISSED ALL THE
NOT VOTING IN. WE WILL NOW GO
ON TO MR MEN'S BUILDING WILL
PRESENT ON SB FIVE HUNDRED IS
BY MISTER MAN I HAVE A MOTION-
BY MISS REAVIS AND A SECOND BY-
MR STONE. THE THANK YOU A CHECK
IS ALSO PRESENTING SB FIVE
HUNDRED AUTHORED BY SENATOR MEN
WHICH REQUIRES ALL NEW LIGHT
DUTY AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES UNDER
848-000-5001 POUNDS TO BE ZERO
EMISSION BY MODEL YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY ONE THIS MEASURE HELPS
OUR STATED SHE BRANDISHES YET
NECESSARY CLEAN AIR GOALS
SPECIALS WE KNOW VEHICLE
EXHAUST BE SOME OF THE MOST
TOXIC POLLUTANTS COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH SB FIVE HUNDRED
ARE MINOR AN OBSERVABLE THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE DMB UPDATING
ITS IT SYSTEMS TO DEPARTMENTS
EXPECTED. TO DO THEREFORE IT'S
REASONABLE TO EXPECT ME TO
INCORPORATE ANY OF ITS I. T.
UPDATES INTO HIS NEW SYSTEM
SMART POLICIES ARE NEEDED TO
SECURE AB DEPLOYMENT ALONG WITH
OTHER PARTS THE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM TOWARDS A SHARED ZERO
EMISSIONS FUTURE WHICH IS WHY
WE NEED SB FIVE HUNDRED THANK
YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
WONDERFUL DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. TO SB
FIVE HUNDRED ON THE LINE.
OPERATOR FOR THOSE OF YOU
WATCHING THE SPEAKER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE TWENTY SEVEN. AND I WOULD
ON BEHALF OF NARAL AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE OTHER
PHONE LINES THAT SIGNAL BUT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT. BY THREE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. PARDON
ME JUST A MOMENT. WHY TWO
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AARON RODRIGUEZ
AT UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE HUNDRED THANK YOU. M.
FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO. THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU- WILL
BRING IT BACK I SEE NOBODY IN
THE GALLERY ONE SPEAK ON SB
FIVE HUNDRED WILL BRING IT
BACK- TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. BUT IT. IS IT. SHOULD
ON THIS BILL AND WE DON'T HAVE.
AN IMMEDIATE FISCAL IMPACT.
GIVEN THE ESTABLISHMENT IS
CRITICIZED ON TILL AFTER
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN. HOWEVER DMV NOTES THAT
THE COST TO PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS WOULD BE RELATIVELY
MINOR. SYSTEMS CHANGES WOULD
ALSO BE REQUIRED BUT ONCE- BUT
SINCE THEY WILL OCCUR ONCE
DMV'S COMPREHENSIVE I. T.
pANTICIPATED TO BE COMPLETE
THESE. ARE COSTS WILL BE MINOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE I SEE NO
COMMENT THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER KALRA FOR ALSO TAKING
CARE OF DR PAM'S BILLS- WILL GO
HEAD TO SB THREE TWENTY SIX.
THAT ENJOY THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OF EMOTION BY
MISS RIVAS SAVE A SECOND BY
MISS CALDERON- YOU MAY PROCEED.
THIS IS A GOOD BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY- WONDERFUL-
DOCTOR PANTS SB. THREE TWENTY
SIX IS THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. OPERATOR HARD ME
MANAGER DID YOU WANT TO GO TO
THE PHONE LINES YES I'M SORRY
AND WE'RE GOING TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO DOCTOR PANS SB
THREE TWENTY SIX. ONE NINE ZERO
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO DISPEL. GO TO
LINE ONE NINETY SEVEN. AB ONE
REPRESENTING AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION WE'RE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND ONE MOMENT FOR THE
NEXT PERSON. GOING TO GO TO
LINE. THREE THIRTY. WAREHOUSING
THANK YOU. FINE TUNE NINETY
NINE. IF HI IT IS LIBERTY.
THANK YOU LIBERTY. THANK YOU
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
WONDERFUL THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK I SEE NOBODY AND THE
CHAMBERS WILL GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SB. THREE
TWENTY SIX. FINANCE HAS NO
POSITIONAL THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE OUT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES INDICATES THIS BILL
FISCAL IMPACTS ARE NONE TOO
MINOR AND ABSORBABLE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO
QUESTIONS THAT GETS OUT- WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING BUT MISS
DOLLY VOTING YES. AND THE FINAL
BILL PRESENTATION THAT YOU'VE
BEEN SO KIND AND SO THAT WE CAN
GET THROUGH- IT'S ACTUALLY
COMMITTEE BILL FROM THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE- SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE WE HAVE A MOTION
BY- MISTER BRYANT IN THE SECOND
BY MR STONE YOU MAY PROCEED.
SMOOTHLY AS RIVAL IN THIS
COMMITTEE BILL. WONDERFUL ON
THIS COMMITTEE BILL SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE. WE'LL GO TO PHONE
LINES. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO PRESS. ONE ZERO.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE TWO OH
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
BREAD MADE ON BE APPLE CAL PAGE
IN SUPPORT. NINETY TWO NINETY
NINE. HELLO AGAIN MORENO THIS
IS LIBERTY IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOUNG. LINE. THREE THIRTY FOUR.
WE KNOW THAT CAN RUNS BUT WHERE
DID YOU. SB SEVEN FOUR. BY.
THREE THIRTY FIVE. HI MY NAME
IS SUPER MADERA COUNTY AND I
CAN'T WAIT TO RECALL GAVIN CALE.
COULD BLIND. THREE THIRTY ONE.
HI THIS IS JANE PARISH OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
WOULD SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU OPERATOR WILL
GO AHEAD AND SEE IF ANYONE IN
THE GALLERY WANTS TO SPEAK I
SEE NOBODY WILL TAKE IT TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT. OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES DO NOT ANTICIPATE ANY
COSTS RELATED TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I'M WITH
THAT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND- TAKE
THAT IS YOUR CLOSEST MISTER
KALRA- THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR.
HELPING US GET THROUGH TOSE
NOW WE WILL TAKE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR- BY MR
BIGELOW A SECOND BY MR STONE
AND IF YOU CAN READ THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- PLEASE. ACR NINETY
FIVE CUNNINGHAM SB SIX ONE FOUR
TWO LETTER SB FOUR THREE FOUR
BATES SB FIVE FOUR ONE BATES AS
BEFORE- NINE CAMARO. SB THREE
TWENTY EGGMAN SB THREE FIVE TWO
EGGMAN SB FOUR HUNDRED JONES S.
B. FIVE FOUR NINE JONES. SB TWO
EIGHTY LIMóN S. B. FOUR NINE
SEVEN LI MON SB SEVEN FIVE
SEVEN LIMON SB TWO THREE ONE
MCGUIRE SB SIX SIX ONE NEWMAN
SB SEVEN FIVE THREE ROTH SB
THREE EIGHT SIX AMBERG. SB FIVE
AND WILK S. B. EIGHT ONE NINE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION. S. B. EIGHT TWO
SIX COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT SB EIGHT TO SEVEN
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
YEAH THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL AT THIS TIME WHEN YOU READ
THE BILLS THAT ARE BEING MOVED
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. SB FORTY
FOUR ALLEN SB SIXTY SIX ALLEN
SB THREE FOUR THREE ALLEN SB
FORTY THREE ALLEN SP SIX ONE
ONE ALLEN. SB TWO FOUR FOUR
ARCHULETA SB SIX FOUR THREE
ARCHER LET SB EIGHT HUNDRED
ARCHER LET ACE. SB EIGHT A ONE
A TWO LETTER. SB TWO FOUR EIGHT
BATES SB SEVEN ONE EIGHT BATES
SB THREE FIVE FIVE BECKER SB
FIVE OH FOUR BECKER SB SEVEN
SIX SEVEN BECKER. SB SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE BECKER S. B. TWO
BRADFORD SB FIVE TWO ONE
BRADFORD SB FIVE SIX SEVEN
BRADFORD. SB FIVE EIGHT SIX
BRADFORD SB SEVEN TEN BRADFORD.
SB SEVEN FOUR THREE BRADFORD SB
SEVEN NINE SIX BRADFORD SB
TWENTY EIGHT COMING YEAR- SB
THREE SIX FIVE CABALLERO. SB
THREE NINE FIVE CABALLERO SB
FOUR SEVEN TWO CABALLERO S. B.
THREE SEVEN CORTES C. S. B.
THREE SIX NINE TWO CORTES E. SB
SEVEN NINE ONE CORTES C. SB
THREE NINE SIX DOLLARS S. B.
SEVEN NINE NET CARBS GIVE ME SB
NINE NINE. DODD SB ONE OH NINE
DOT S. B. TWO TWO TWO DIED SB
THREE THREE TWO DODD SB TWO
SEVEN ZERO DRAW SO. SB THREE
TWO ONE ZERO SO SB SIX THREE
NINE DORADO SB SIX SEVEN FOUR
DROUGHT SO SB SEVEN THREE ONE
DORADO ESPYS TWO SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN. EGGMAN SB THREE ONE SIX
EGGMAN SB THREE EIGHTY EGGMAN
SB NINETEEN GLAZER. SB FOUR
FOUR SIX GLAZER SB SEVEN FOUR
FOUR GLAZER SB SEVEN FOUR NINE
GLAZER SB EIGHT OH FOUR GLAZER.
SB THREE THREE EIGHT GONZALEZ
SB SIX OH SIX GONZALEZ SB SIX
SEVEN ONE GONZALEZ. SB SEVEN
TWO SIX GONZALEZ SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX GONZALEZ SB SEVEN EIGHT TWO
EIGHT SEVEN THREE TWO EIGHT
SEVEN GROVE. SB THREE FOUR
EIGHT GROVE SB TWO SIX TWO
HERTZBERG SB TWO SEVEN TWO SIX
SEVEN HERTZBERG. SB THREE FOUR
FOUR HERTZBERG SB SIX FOUR SIX
HERTZBERG. SB FIVE EIGHT NINE
WEST SO SB SIX TWO FOUR WESO
XP'S SB SIX EIGHT FOUR WEST SO.
SB SIX EIGHT SEVEN WEST SO. SB
THREE NINE THREE OR TITLE. SB
FOUR OH TWO OR TOTAL SB FOUR TO
EIGHT HER. DAUGHTER S. B. SEVEN
SEVEN JONES S. B. FOR WHEN NINE
LAYERED. SB THREE EIGHT LAYERED
SB FOUR FIVE SIX LAYARD SP ONE
SIX ONE NINE LAYERED. SB TWO
NINE NINE LEYVA. SB THREE SEVEN
TWO LEYVA SB FIVE TO THREE
LEYVA SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN LEYVA
SP FOUR SEVEN LIMON SB FIFTY
LIMON SB THREE SIX EIGHT LIMóN
SB FIVE THREE EIGHT LIVE ON SB
SEVEN OH TO LIVE ON. SB SIX
NAME ACQUIRE HE SB EIGHTY
MCGUIRE SB NINETY EIGHT MCGUIRE
S. B. TWO OH SIX BUT WHY SB
FIVE FIVE FIVE AND WIRE SB
SEVEN SIXTEEN MCGUIRE S. B. TWO
SIX FOUR MEN S. B. FIVE ONE TWO
MIN. SB SIX OR SEVEN MEN SB SIX
FIVE FOUR MEN SB SEVENTY SIX
NIELSEN. SB. THREE THREE SIX
SHOW UP ALL THAT- AS- CORRECT.
SB SEVENTY FIVE ISSUE OF- SB
THREE OH SIX PAN SB FIVE NINE
EIGHT PAN SB SEVEN FOUR TWO
PAN. SB TWO TO FOUR PORTANTINO
SB TWO FIVE FIVE PORTANTINO SB
THREE EIGHT ONE PORTANTINO SB
FIVE SIX TWO PORTANTINO. SB
SEVEN ONE FIVE PORTANTINO SB
NINETY SEVEN ROTH SB EIGHT OH
TWO ROTH ESPINO THREE ROCK THIS
VETO SIX ROTH. SB TWO THREE
RUBIO SB FOUR EIGHT EIGHT RUBIO
S. B. SIX TWO RUBIO SB EIGHT OH
FIVE RUBIO S. B. ONE SIX
SKINNER S. B. ONE EIGHT. ASKIN
SB TWO SEVEN SKINNER SB SIX
FIVE SKINNER SB FIVE TO FOUR
SKINNER S. B. SIX THREE STERN.
SB SIX TO EIGHT FOUR STERN SB
FOUR OR SIX STERN. SB FORTY
THREE STERN SB FIVE FIVE ONE
STERN SB SEVEN NINETY STERN SB
FORTY ONE- BURKE. SB TWO FOR
ONE- BURKE SB THREE FOUR NINE
NUMBER SB THREE SIX SIX- BURKE.
SB THREE NINE NINE NUMBER SB
FOUR TWENTY HUMBER SB SIX SIX
FIVE ON BURKE AS SB ONE TEN
WIENER SB TWO TWO ONE WIENER SB
TWO FIVE TO WIENER. SB THREE
ONE FOUR WINNER SB THREE FIVE
SEVEN WIENER AS BEFORE SEVEN
SEVEN WIENER. SB FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT WIENER S. B. FIVE FOUR
SIX WILK. THANK YOU I'M GONNA
ASK I'M- WHO WANT TO REGISTER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO ANY
THE BILLS THAT WERE ON CONSENT
OR MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
WHERE THE AUTHOR HAS WAY
PRESENTATION TO DO THAT IN
WRITING WE ARE GOING TO END
TODAY'S MEETING. AND IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO REDRESS YOUR
GOVERNMENT AS I YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT YOU CAN DO
SO IN WRITING BY EMAIL OR SNAIL
MAIL TO OUR COMMITTEE. YOU CAN
FIND ON OUR I'M SORRY NOT SNAIL
MAIL IT OUR OUR MAIL CARRIERS
WORK HARD I CAN SAY THAT. M.
BUT WE WILL. GO AHEAD AND ADD
THOSE WE HAVE. TO WORK TO MORE
SUSPENSE ITEMS I'M SORRY THAT
WE MISSED SB EIGHT TWENTY
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION SB EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE. THANK YOU THAT
CONCLUDES OUR APPROPRIATIONS
MEETING TODAY. SORRY. YEAH.